this is Jocko podcast number 405 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
the enemy rounds continued hitting the
wall and edges of the Rooftop
Michael had taken the bulk of the blast
and shrapnel his wounds were many and
Grievous
with enemy gunfire increasing Benny knew
that if he didn't get back on a gun none
of them were going to make it off of the
roof
he did not want to leave Michael's side
but this was the only thing left that he
could do Benny grabbed Michael's Mark 48
and went to work
he sent long continuous outbursts back
at the enemy the pain from his wounds
faded into rage
by this point the Iraqi Scouts had made
their way back onto the rooftop and
began to help Benny with the fight
Guided by Doug and Mike S
the rooftop was taking heavy fire from
multiple enemy automatic weapons
Seth you guys need to get here fast Doug
and I are hurt bad and Mikey is down
hard Mike S called into the radio
he did not know that Seth and his team
were already on the way to reach their
position
got you we're coming hang in there guys
the Bradleys are on their way
Seth called back in response
Seth's element had heard and seen the
two blasts from their OverWatch position
and were already moving when the call
for help came in
the men urgently picked up the pace when
they heard the amount of enemy automatic
weapon fire that their friends were
receiving
they broke out from the main entrance
and headed west initially all was quiet
at their position but within 15 seconds
of hitting the street all hell broke
loose
enemy rounds snapped and skipped around
them
they moved from cover to cover returning
fire as they closed the distance to the
other OverWatch position
suddenly a seal from the other element
burst onto the roof and headed over to
Doug Mike S and Michael
he was followed by Seth and the other
seals one of the strongest seals grabbed
Michael and hoisted him onto his back
Seth grabbed Doug and the other the
others took Mike S
they could hear the 25 millimeter Auto
Cannons of the Bradley Fighting Vehicles
begin to fire effectively suppressing
the enemy and providing cover for the
seals to load their wounded
when the wounded seals arrived back at
Camp Corregidor
they saw the men from the first of the
506 lined up waiting to support wherever
they could another Testament to the bond
that the two units shared
Doug Mike S and Michael were loaded onto
stretchers and brought into the Aid
Station on the camp
Doug and Mike S were given shots of
morphine
and for the first time since the grenade
explosion they finally had reprieve from
the piercing physical pain
the reprieve however was short-lived
the atmosphere in the room shifted the
mood had darkened and the two men could
feel it
then they overheard the nurse say it
Michael was gone
in that sobering moment they became
aware of what Michael had given them
he had freely exchanged his life
for theirs
it was September 29th
the feast of Saint Michael the Archangel
the archangel
the protector and guide of War Fighters
since time Memorial
and whom Michael had been named after
25 years earlier
and that right there is an excerpt
from the book defend Us in battle the
true story of Medal of Honor recipient
Michael a Mansour which was written by
George Mansour
Michael's father
and it was an honor to have George
on the podcast number 359.
to share the story of his son Mikey
who was part of Seal Team three tasking
a Bruiser when he jumped on a grenade
to absorb the blast
and save three of her other teammates
three of her other friends three of her
other brothers
and the
strong seal who grabbed Michael and
hoisted him onto his back to carry him
out to the Bradleys was another teammate
and another friend of mine another
brother named Jimmy May
and Jimmy served for over 22 years in
the Navy most of that time 20 plus years
as a seal
he led troops in combat in both Iraq and
Afghanistan he led training he's a jiu
jitsu practitioner he attended Harvard
Business School
and he's been a friend of mine since the
day we met in ramadi which happened to
be on August 2nd 2006 the day that Mark
Lee was killed
and it's an honor to have Jimmy with us
here tonight to share some of his
experiences and Lessons Learned
Jimmy thanks for coming by man thanks
for having me and you jump right into
the heavy stuff we're not going to mess
around all right yeah well
um
I mean that's obviously a day we'll
never forget and something that the more
people know and understand and recognize
and remember the better off we'll all be
so
I'm sure we'll get there we'll we'll
talk about that day
um
but let's let's let's talk about how we
got there and how we got here today
let's talk about you where you came from
let's start at the beginning so what
Texas kid
yeah Texas but El Paso so it's kind of
like right on the border it's very much
uh
I mean the Mexican influence is all over
the place I spoke a lot of Spanish
growing up uh I had nicknames like
Weddle or leche or anything else that
means white and you know I still to this
day feel very comfortable in that Latin
culture you know I spend a lot of time
in Mexico working playing surfing do you
still speak do you speak Spanish I speak
it okay I speak Spanglish I would never
do it here on because I probably say a
lot of bad words and I'm not supposed to
say because I didn't learn it in a
classroom you know what I mean you know
how that goes yeah so what were your
what were your mom and dad doing growing
up uh I didn't see my dad much because
my dad had three jobs he worked at
Gibson's which is like uh Vons or
something like that and he worked at
7-Eleven and then he my uncle lived with
us too he worked at you know Pizza Hut
we were I mean probably below a poverty
family for most of the time
um you know my mom she worked too and as
I got older they ended up my mom went to
college because they're like we got to
do better than this you know and so my
mom went to college and when I went to
high school they both finished but I was
mostly lower middle class for my my life
and then I didn't know what to do when I
got out of high school during High
School I was a wrestler football player
and then I just never thought I thought
colleges for Rich Kids I never thought I
could go how good of a wrestler were you
I was decent I I took fifth in the state
of Texas my senior year
um but you know the guys are going to
really win they all come from Iowa those
Midwestern like good grindy States you
know what I mean those guys are they
start early and they're Cut Above at
least at that time and what about
football football is decent uh I played
a lot but I wasn't going to go to
college on it I'm a little fella you
know I'm not as big as you guys walking
around but I played you know cornerback
and then Wing back so I was in and out
as a receiver and then I returned punts
and kicks I was relatively fast um for
back then what about school did you pay
attention in school did you try in
school no I didn't try at all I just I
was like I'll just enlist in the
military like the rest of my family did
almost I think at that point every adult
male had been in the military most of
them thrown out for something a lot of
them got in trouble
um but I was just gonna enlist had your
dad been in the military my dad was a
hawk missile Tech in the Army and uh he
got out he didn't say much about it but
I do remember like you know my dad died
all the things he did I didn't know much
about armor service on this Tombstone it
said U.S army and it had the dates he
served I'm like that's interesting of
all the things it has his army service
on his Tombstone I don't know it just
kind of was interesting to me so so
you're growing up your parents are
working all the time did you have
brothers sisters yeah I got a younger
sister and they got a younger brother so
my sister's two years younger than my
brothers uh he's five years younger than
I am and were you kind of like the man
of the house then a bunch with their if
they were working all the time I was
kind of a I kind of picked on him a lot
I gotta say like I was kind of like the
quintessential big brother like tying
them up and doing stuff and messing with
them you know like letting the spit drop
right back there and suck it back up you
know I kind of picked on him a lot uh
we're pretty close now though I'm happy
to say you know my brothers started no
College started super successful cell
phone tower business he puts light bulbs
on cell towers he's crushing it and then
my sister she's a teacher she's just and
she works for me and I actually was made
the executive I a pair to do all the
things I don't know how to do and she's
awesome trust lowers the cost of
transactions she's got my social my
credit cards and everything you know
what take it and I just trust her she
pays her own I don't even pay attention
to it she takes some money she said
website for me I really haven't seen it
I don't deal with it so so you're you're
growing up in El Paso and basically it's
a bunch of I've been to El Paso it's
like like you said it's a huge Mexican
Community are you getting into trouble
are you staying out of trouble what was
keeping you from
like getting in a lot of trouble yeah so
I got in I should have been in more
trouble I used to go I rode the rodeo
for a little bit I rode Bulls walking
around there and then I also used to go
I'd go to Juarez which is like the
sister city of El Paso in Mexico because
you could drink down there and then I'd
actually box in smokers down there
sometimes and uh just did all sorts of
stuff that my family was pretty appalled
at and that was really hard to control
because me and my dad kind of had it out
when I was about 16 17 and we really
didn't talk much until I left again for
the Navy it was a it was a really
tension relationship was he trying to
like control you and you didn't like
that he was super controlling but I'm
also kind of hard to control you work
with me you know it's I had my own
attitude and my dad he trying to he
tried to confront by intimidation but I
was a wrestler football player after
about 16 you can't do that anymore you
know you probably should do it a
different way and we got frustrated with
me and you know we didn't talk much but
you know he's dead now he died of cancer
when I was when I was finishing buds but
he really turned it around I have to say
you know his last two years he saw the
writing on the wall and he you know
swallowed some Jagged pills and you know
really manned up and became a pretty
awesome person so I'm happy to say he
figured it out yeah you know your kids
are if you're trying your kids are going
to Rebel at some level and the more you
try and control them the harder they're
going to Rebel the worse it's going to
be and by the way like you just
mentioned like oh you know I'm hard to
control I I work for you but like I
never felt like that with you I never
felt like any I didn't feel like you
were controlling me exactly you kind of
like gave me a direction and you'd look
at me and like hey that's a bad call and
you explain to me why and then you
didn't control me I don't I never felt
like a Jocko's bullying me right now you
know yeah except on the mat
it's it's it's a good perspective to
have you know especially from that kid
when you're raising kids like if you're
gonna try and get them to do exactly
what it is you want them to do there's a
decent chance they're gonna kind of say
no I'm not doing that and they're
probably gonna go harder and it's the
same thing not just with kids it's the
same thing like you know with with your
people that work if you're in a
leadership position people that work for
you you can do the same thing you can
piss them off as well and you'd be super
controlling and but you might think well
but my way really is better and great
your way really is better now you got a
bunch of people that don't want to work
for you they're not going to give it the
full effort you're not gonna see
everything because you're down there
trying to control everything that's
going on so just
just don't be a micromanager as a parent
or as a leader that's my recommendation
yeah and then you also I remember one
time I was so vivid like I came back
from an op and we were doing something
and you were like where were you and I
couldn't find the spot we were on the
map dude I never felt so embarrassed in
my entire life you're like no no show me
I'm like well and we're over in eastern
you're like well show me on the map
because I want to hear it and you knew
you knew that I didn't know where we
were and I was so embarrassed and to
this day that like we used to hiked
across the Grand Canyon I had a map out
every stop because it was so ingrained
him I was like I cannot believe how
embarrassed I was
yeah that knowing where you are and
that's something that when I was a young
seal uh we when I was going through seal
tactical training which was what became
sqt yeah and it just was with the like
20 guys 20 new guys that still team one
and we would go out on patrol and do
every different position and you know
like one time I was rear security and
then I was a weird security for four
hours and you have no idea where you are
and it's it was so frustrating to me
because when I was a when I was a
Communications guy I would be close
enough to like the officer in the
appointment to be like looking at their
map looking on them you know like see
where we're at but no one else in the
platoon would know where we were and
that was before GPS yeah yeah you know
what I mean and you gotta stop and mean
meaningfully take out your map and
spread it out and put your red lens low
to the ground and all those things it's
a pain so when I became an officer I
would always do my absolute best to make
sure everyone knew that where we were
and then also when I was in E5 and I was
now teaching at Seal Team one and I
would have these officers that didn't
know where they were yeah and I would be
like oops you know I'd break out my map
and be like hey you know where are you
if they didn't know I would just like
try and explain to them if you don't
know where you are you can't call for
fire support you can't call for an
extract you can't do anything you can't
you can't even really navigate to
anywhere because you don't even know
where you are so yes if I probably
detected that you might not have known
exactly where you are I knew it too and
I was trying to get out of there I was
trying to get out of that office and you
weren't having it until I clearly
explained that I couldn't tell you
exactly where I was yeah oh right on
um all right so it seems like uh life in
El Paso was looking like a little bit of
a dead end but you're like cool I'm
gonna join the military no Factor well I
didn't know what I was going to do so I
went I took a test and I I did Super
well in the ASVAB I'm not a super
academic guy I end up getting like a 99
what I think is the top so you can do
whatever you want and so we used to do
nuclear power you get automatic E3 and
you'll be E4 after nine months I'm like
that sounds like I want to make some
money and so I wanted a nuclear power I
didn't have any idea what was going on
no I had no clue know why I joined the
Navy yeah just FYI the nuclear power
program in the foreign in the Navy
is a really hard program and it's a
really hard job
it's a very technical hard like down in
the freaking engine rooms on a nuclear
aircraft carrier or a submarine nuclear
sub like it is a freaking hard job and
the there's no margin for error like
it's a really tough training program and
it's a tough job so
they just signed you up like hey you'll
make E3 and you're like yo sounds good I
think they get bonus for like science I
think it's like hey we can get a nuke in
here and so I got to boot camp I did
real well at boot camp I got you know I
was like the Navy League guy and I was
the honor recruit in boot camp and I'm
like oh and maybe this but I just
I just didn't like it I'm like okay so I
get to nuclear power school that was
pretty hard I had to study a lot you
know me you guys would call me coconut
you know not smart hard
yeah anyway and so I get there and I
studied hard I mean it was hard but I
had like a 3-1 GPA I worked real hard
and uh I didn't like it though I could
tell this isn't for me you know
um and one day I was coming back I
finished nuclear power school and then
you go to the thing called prototype
where you like practice running a
nuclear actor and this lady's car broke
down the side of the road uh I was
coming back from Daytona Beach and I
pulled over it's not that hard to fix it
was like the radiator gasket between the
upper radiator hose and the intake
manifold not a big deal scraped it
bought a little cut a gasket at AutoZone
put it on there for her she's like hey
man uh can I give you some money for
this and she gave me 30 bucks for pizza
which I thought was fair you know so I
took it it was a Seal's wife and you
know that Thursday we're I'm like I
snuck my book in to the to the assembly
because no one's talked to me I'm a
stupid student I'm just trying to study
because I studied a lot wait which
assembly is this it was like this so
they had an assembly on Thursdays when
the CEO would address everybody like hey
students yeah it's like like an all
hands call yeah and all hands call
correct and and they're like
we're gonna call Jimmy May up here or
James May or Seaman what was that Seaman
Seaman May yeah I'm like and someone's
like hey they're calling you I'm like
there's no way they're calling me that
no they're calling you I get up there
and the lady walks out and uh the
captain
and I'm like hey I recognize you and
Captain like you guys is my wife he's
like okay thank you and then he gave me
a little letters of like nice city or
something I don't know what they call it
the opposite of a reprimand it was like
a good thing but it's not quite big
enough to like wear a ribbon yeah
whatever that middle ground is and then
he's like if I can ever help you let me
know I was like well I gotta I got an
offshore pack of gym but it's not going
well because my SATs aren't that good
I'm like an 1100 guy and they're like
because they give it to me
Boom turn around next thing you know I'm
going to Texas A M so
dang dudes yeah all right so now it's
going to Texas A M but you're going as a
E3 or something well I went in there and
they wanted me to go into the core
Cadets
and you know I really had a problem with
it because you show up and these guys
are yelling at me about military stuff
and none of them been in the military
you know they're a year ahead of you and
they're supposed to be yelling and I was
over it I'm like are you kidding me I
was such a problem child to my
upperclassmen because I just I mean I
had a job because I had a daughter in
college and I had to make money and I
remember I came back from work one night
and they had tore up my room
oh so mad I'm like who did this and I'm
not gonna say their names because I
still remember their names and like I
went in the room and I told I pulled
their racks over and tore up their room
I was so pissed and then uh
and then it was interesting they went
short to do with me and I end up
eventually getting thrown out of the
core Cadets and the core cadets at at
there is like ROTC basically is that
what it is if when I was there there was
like 2 000 people there but only ten
percent of going to military so a lot of
them it's almost like a
military-esque kind of a club thing but
uh you know they do a lot of leadership
training and stuff and it's got a really
good history I'm not going to like talk
about about the corcadets it just I just
had a real hard time getting yelled at
about military stuff the people that
have been in the military and I'm like
you know actually uh Mike S from the
book was there at the same time I was oh
right now yeah yeah and he didn't even
play the game at all he like he's he's
like I've been a marine I'm going I'm
moving off campus but he was smarter
than I was it took me a couple years
before they had enough of me and said
you're just going to go off campus and
stop this okay right on and then how are
you doing school
uh so I
I kind of I I didn't study but I found
ways around things you know like they
used to have a great distribution they'd
publish which okay which teachers have
the easiest classes so I would like do
that find the easiest classes and go to
those and then I would you know I was
always you know dating like a a girl
that was in the some Athletics they had
the old test which isn't legal because
they have a test bank and so basically
if they have like 600 questions they
choose 50 of them for the test if you
study all the old questions
you can do fine the test so I always
found ways around things I never really
tried to learn I had to work a lot I
worked like 40 hours a week and what
were you doing for a job I was a
bartender at a steakhouse I would say
it's like a uh like an Outback caliber
but it's uh it was called Oxford Street
so it was like an like an English themed
and it was good because I didn't have a
lot of money for food and so I used to
have this rule when I was busing tables
like okay if I'd kiss her I'll eat after
her so like that's how I got to
otherwise I couldn't afford food so we
just and you had so you had when was
your daughter what year of college did
you did you have your daughter my it was
she was born in 99 I got there in 96 but
I had to start working right away as
well so she was born in 1999 so correct
Alex was with my sophomore junior year
and at what point did you hear about the
seal teams did you already know about
them did you learn about them in regular
Navy boot camp like what how'd that come
out this is such a like un like an
amazing story I was just kind of beside
myself with everything I was just kind
of grumpy I'm like I went to the Navy I
didn't like it it seemed ridiculous to
me college is ridiculous I don't go to
class I have a 36 GPA this is ridiculous
like what is there anything hard and my
uncle he was uh he'd been in the Navy he
was one of the guys who did a good job
he ended up being a warrant officer when
he got out I believe and he's like you
know the seals are hard but you
shouldn't do it I'm like why he goes you
won't make it
like how come he goes nobody makes it
I'm like hmm
that's it so I I didn't even really
think about what a seal did or anything
I just wanted to try to get through buds
because I was looking for something hard
and it was hard so did you start
training hard yeah I did yeah there was
a little group at Texas A M so I really
like say I struggled with the core
Cadets thing I didn't like wearing
uniform in the morning and there was a
group there of guys who wanted to be
seals and they just got up earlier than
everybody else like 30 minutes earlier
you ran out you had a crazy hard workout
and then you showed up to Chow late but
you could actually eat because like if
you're a regular Cadet every time you're
up a classroom and talk to you just spit
your food out and you had to sit at
attention and you had you know all those
games you talk about at OCS it was kind
of like that for milk but you could you
had to have the same ever had the same
food unified Chow it was ridiculous and
when I want these guys I could sit down
and I could eat good nutrition I just
destroyed my body now I can get good
nutritious food and now I can't go
drinking every night because I got a
pretty hard workout to do the next day
so it really like put some discipline
and structure and a lot of those guys
became seals so all those guys that you
know my upperclassmen they were they
didn't treat me I was a freshman they
didn't treat me like a turd you know
what I mean like show up you do your
stuff and I really found my Niche and
that group so it's good for me so it's
hard very hard to get a Billet for to go
to buds as an officer how the hell did
you pull that off
so I I didn't have the greatest grades I
mean decent but you know nowadays
especially all of our O's are like 40
ivy league guys you know and uh I went
to this thing called mini buds back then
and mini buds was like
a little taste of hell you know you do
like two weeks of buds then you do two
weeks with with the team going around
like some Geo gets stuck with having to
show some you know mid shipment around
and but the two weeks in mini buds I did
really well and uh they give the top
three guys a contract and so out of mini
buds I end up getting a contract along
with uh I know the other two officers
actually that and they did pretty well
in the teams too so it was uh that's how
I got it yeah that's hard that's a hard
thing to do hard thing to pull off so
you get done you graduate from college
and then it's going to buds how how buds
work out for you what year is it now
it's like 2001 2001 yeah I I got I
graduated August 19th in the summer I
took a bit of a Victory lap I was like
done the five and a half year plan for
college and then uh I get there in
September and they're like hey we got a
slot to get this next class I'm like yes
let's go let's jump into it and so I
jumped right into class 238 the only
thing I failed the whole time was drown
proofing I'm pretty negatively buoyant
like uh it seems like a lot of like the
black guys had a hard time because
they're pretty negative too well I was
in that ilk of those guys that had a
hard time uh being negative you don't
have enough combat swimmer muscle that's
what I need yeah too lean I get cold
yeah but uh yeah like so I did
everything fine but I couldn't float and
you gotta do a two minute float and so I
failed and the instructor I was sitting
with the other nine guys that failed
they're like hey if anyone could pass
right now this is your last chance to
get back into Buds and the instructor
not so I'm like I can do it the only guy
no one else tried so I jumped back in
the guy's like hey look you're not going
to float and it was a black dude and
he's like you need to swim in circles
that's all he told me and then I got
back and and I did it and I you know and
John proof is pretty tiring you know I
did it back to back the second time it
takes about 25 minutes it's even more
tiring if you don't float it is super
tiring if you don't because like for me
I was floating you know like the time
when you were swimming in circles I was
just chilling I was just over here
cruising I'm swimming in circles
struggling yeah so dude there was a guy
it was a black guy in my class he was
from Africa super good dude you know but
he had like a cool African like British
type accent and dude he when they would
pushed him into the water like tied up
for drown proofing I'm not kidding he
just sank to the bottom like like a
brick like a like a brick like just
right to the bottom and just didn't move
he just was down there yeah and I was
like bro it was a bar he didn't he ended
up not making it yeah but he needed some
uh like real help yeah and some pizzas
you know like because he was shredded
bro like you know like he was just
shredded yeah shredded
um so you use what was your first like
impression of buds though like when you
showed up there man I was just waiting
for the thing I couldn't do I'm like
there's going to be something here
that's going to be so crazy I can't do
it and it just wasn't it was I mean it's
a lot you know you run six miles a day
just to eat back and forth from like you
know breakfast lunch dinner that's not
even on the schedule that just happens
and then you know I was just pretty
stoked to be in what I thought you know
is probably arguably some of the world's
hardest military training so I just was
excited about that still hadn't thought
about what happens after and of course
I'm in first phase when 9 11 happened
and uh you know instructors tried to put
some levity on that for us and I was
like okay things are about to change
what phase were you in first phase when
first phase we were about to do a Four
Mile time run and we were eating
breakfast because we had like the
morning PT and I was just you know as
you should officers eat last so I get in
and the class is still giant you know
the class starts off with like ours was
155 we had 22 Originals finished which
actually is not too bad and uh you know
there's just all these people and I'm
just trying to Wolf down whatever food I
can get because I'm starving you know in
buds you just you if you're not running
you're shivering or you're carrying
something heavy that's pretty much what
buds is for six months and so I got the
metabolism of hummingbird anyway so I'm
like just trying to keep stuff what did
you weigh when you checked in the bugs
165 okay yeah what do you know what are
you walking around right now 175 sure
yeah so I've lost a little bit we'll
talk about later I'm sure but I've got
my hips replaced too yeah I'm still on
the recovery yeah yeah so what do you
remember about like guys that made it
versus guys that didn't I was shocked
that who didn't there was some badass
dudes that I was like oh dude yeah and
then when they quit a bunch of people
quit with them because they're like I
don't know if they felt Vindicated like
okay I made it as long as that guy did
so maybe it's okay or I don't I don't
know but like you would see like a big
tough dude quit and like three dudes
would quit with them yeah and I remember
during hell week everyone was quitting
and it just sound like they're ringing
the bell I thought the instructors were
messing with me because the ring the
bell's just ringing continuously you
know and I remember I'm like what
happened to all the boat Crews there's
like three or four of them left you know
so I used to be the EXO at buds it's
actually super scripted so I mean down
to every minute it feels like Mayhem
when you're in it but when you watch it
you're like dang this is a it's super
tight yeah so you're going through and
it seems like Mayhem because you're a
student when you're going through it I
know for I never was an instructor at
buds
I don't regret it or anything but I wish
I would have worked a couple hell weeks
or something just to like see behind the
like behind the scenes of what was going
down yeah it's it's a lot and we we did
we made some major changes to the way we
you know when I was XO there we ended up
having someone kill themselves and we we
stood up this whole new thing called the
ahrock which is really interesting I
don't know if I want to jump ahead into
that yeah we'll do we'll get there on
that let's uh stick with where you're
going so no issues other than drown
proofing first phase hell week no Factor
no I did pretty well on that what time
of year did you go through a week uh it
was uh October November how was your how
is your chili chili dude it was so cold
we had we had to carry on the stupid
pumpkin all the time and the instructors
would try to break it and they're like
you better let destructive break a
pumpkin and so like on top of that with
a stupid pumpkin I remember right
Charlie was his name I still remember
that stupid pumpkin's name and uh yeah I
mean I don't know I I didn't hell week
sucked but it was long but I don't
remember like ever everyone's like
everyone thinks about quitting like I
didn't really I was like this is this is
hard there's gonna be something I can't
do in there just wasn't you know so you
were in pretty good shape when you
showed up there I was I was ready for
buds yeah I could say that for sure did
you get rolled for anything no the only
thing I felt was that one that one drum
proofing thing and then they didn't roll
did you uh get how about pool comp did
you pass pool comp first time yeah I
think it was first time every time on
everyone except I didn't get you got a
first time every time if you passed
they're called OCS open circuits and
basically one through eight and I think
one of them I failed and it wasn't it
wasn't a big deal but like there's
different a different knot they tie
every time and you got to figure out how
to get it and I I remember one of the
most elate like Elations I felt my
entire life was when they tied the one
where you have they tie a knot in like
your ex your ex exhalation hose and so
you can still get air but it feels like
you can't because it's full of water and
you have to drink the water out and
you're like I'm drinking I'm like please
let there be air in here come on come on
I'm drinking and also I'm like oh my
gosh like I'm so fired up I was like man
I can't smile right now because I was
but I was so happy that there was some
air behind there yeah that's a pool comp
is a gnarly Evolution but you passed it
first time that's pretty impressive
um I I don't know I wasn't super
impressive I was okay I failed that one
thing but everything else you know
so so you end up getting so that's it
you graduate and then it rolls into sqt
yeah I went to so we were the first sqt
class and back then they were like you
this is the first time you're going to
get your Trident after right when you go
show up a team and so now you were
already you're the old guard of the team
and you're like who are these new you
know they had the bird cage where you
had to put your Trident in it and they
spray painted in blue to make them a
nerd you know team two is a little old
school about things we'll leave it at
that and uh they weren't super happy of
us guys showing up there with a bird on
our chest oh you know that must have not
what year was that that was oh two yeah
yeah I left team two in 2000 okay so
yeah I imagined a month lucky that I
missed you I imagine my boys definitely
probably kept it on lock over there at
st2 yeah yeah and so you show up there
and so that means you've already been
through sk2 did you what was your major
like lessons learned during sqt uh sqt
actually was pretty professional I even
back then like they didn't mess with us
too much they were I thought we're
talking I'm still in buds but and just
the fact that they're talking to me like
a human they're trying to teach you
actually things and I remember at the
back side you really thought you knew
what you had like oh I've been to a lot
of schools I'm a dive supervisor and you
know I've been assaults and stuff and
then you get to the team and you realize
like you just barely know anything I get
in the house they're all running and I'm
you know walking the slo-mo walk that we
were doing before this I'm like yeah
so you get do you get put right into a
platoon yeah right Angel platoon
um and it was so it was really it was
actually cool for us we deployed three
months early and that first deployment
was paycom centcom and Yukon so I did
three months in paycom because they
ripped a team one team out to go over to
Afghanistan and then I went to UConn for
three months and then we went over and
we did what turned out to not be a super
fun mission uh PSD personal security
Detachment where we were protecting
Barham Saleh who was the Deputy Prime
Minister of Iraq he was a good dude man
he was a kurd you know I don't know how
you feel about things but the Kurds are
pretty yeah it's a pretty good the Kurds
are are definitely the fighters for sure
oh yeah I've done a lot of work with the
pesh over there and they're they're good
dudes I I feel bad for how it went down
I was over there in 2017 when they tried
to declare independence and you know I
guess I can talk about how I feel about
it now but I was I was upset that we
didn't back them more than we could have
we this was your first platoon is there
one assistant platoon Commander or were
there two of you guys I wasn't coming I
was the third o which was the best deal
of all time they got rid of it which
basically I was a 60 Gunner I carried a
60 as an officer you know people like
officers should so I carried I carried
the 60 and then I did all the travel
claims in the paperwork that was kind of
what I did so like you know I got to get
on the pigs and uh that's a cool thing
when you're a young dude you know what I
mean you don't mind carrying you know 55
pounds in just weapon and ammo yeah I
mean that's the yeah let's go and
that's a pretty awesome deployment
though so you went paycom yep and then
to where Yukon and then do you come yep
over in Europe so you did some exercises
in paycom
um you done paycom yeah we did some with
India we did some stuff with them we did
some stuff with the tie seals and uh the
Indians I learned a lot over there you
know the Indians don't put the same
premium on Life as we do and I remember
that they wanted to do they wanted to
like go right to vbss visit board search
and seizure which basically like
climbing up the side of a boat from like
another boat and like assault it and
they didn't they weren't worried about
the helicopter piece because we normally
do it with two with helicopters the half
Hilo assault force and the bath the
Border salt Force but they just want to
do the boat side but you know you gotta
you got this tiny little ladder that's
wrapped around a gatorade bottle and you
like hook this thing up and you gotta
climb up while the boat's moving and you
need to be able to do a couple pull-ups
you know because you got you're wearing
you're wearing probably about 80 pounds
worth of Kit I think that's a because
you're kind of light when you're going
vbss so 80 pounds is about what you're
wearing and you peel off that ladder not
only are you going to go on the drink
but you could hit someone on the way
down like our good friend cess Stone had
someone on his head remember yeah and
broke his neck so it's a pretty
dangerous thing and I ended up telling
them like hey man we can't do this with
your group right now like we're just
gonna do this and the guy he's like why
not well because uh it's too dangerous
and it's not worth you losing a guy the
guy tells me this training is worth more
than one or two of my guys and I'm like
I'm like listen man that's not the way
we roll so we can't do it they were
pretty upset I didn't get a good Mark
from them but I didn't want to do it
yeah and then ucom ucom uh we just did a
bunch of like uh basically PSD training
learning how to like because we actually
didn't do any PSD during the workup and
now we're going to be protecting you
know a head of state we did some we
protected some other people were over
there it's not a fun mission but you get
cool pictures like it is a fun mission
because lots of time you're sitting in
the green room waiting for them and also
like oh wait they're done or they're
meeting around long and everyone gets up
and leaves their whatever they're doing
and jumps into the cars and gets ready
so it wasn't fun but uh it looks like it
was fun
makes for some cool pictures yeah my mom
actually saw me she saw a picture of me
on like Fox News or something like that
are you in Iraq because I told I was in
Europe and she's like you in Iraq I
think I saw you I'm like yeah
um
and then so you get done with that
deployment and what was your big Lessons
Learned From that deployment
um on that deployment man I was a new
guy I wish I could say that I had some
kind of big profound thing but I really
was just it was so many different things
and I would I was often the Advan and so
you know I didn't have any super
illustrious things to say about that
floor in there I learned a lot on your
first deployment but I can't even put it
into a encapsulated thing yeah it's I I
look at it sort of similar to having
kids your first kid you just know
nothing and you're just like hanging on
and like trying to yeah and you also are
focused on some dumb stuff and like
you're I remember you know my wife was
cleaning like boiling every uh bottle
cap or whatever like oh we gotta this
needs to be boiled and and then by the
time we had our fourth kid like kids are
just eating mud
yeah yes it's good it just doesn't care
yeah but you learn so much and that's it
actually almost equates almost perfectly
to like what you feel like in your first
platoon you're like and then your second
tune you're like okay I can't understand
it third third platoon you're like okay
I got this fourth platoon you're like oh
like six fifth between sixth of the year
just like you know what to do man yeah
so
um
so what what happens when you get done
with that and you all you had another
kid in I did while you were a team too
right yeah I did so did you get married
well yeah we got married right after
right during college before I left and
then uh he was born he was born in May
so I I came I came back early from
deployment two weeks early so I could go
and see him be born right on yeah and
then what's your next
so next up on the so on the on the
gauntlet of nsw every Junior officer is
trying to like get another platoon
that's that's what that's the golden
thing you want to do and so we were all
trying to figure out how we could do it
because they want to like send you off
to do this Associated tour and they had
me take this test and turns out I can
learn languages so they're like hey
you're going to go learn Arabic so I
thought I could just slow roll this
thing until eventually you know someone
gets fired or something and then I'm at
the team because this seemed like a good
call like someone's going to get hurt or
fired or something so but it never
happened so I went off to learn Arabic
and it was I couldn't believe I was
going to miss the whole War I'm like I'm
gonna miss all I did in this whole war
was protect the dude and now I'm going
to be in Arabic school to be done by the
time I get back so I mean I was just
super mad
studied super hard and I ended up
completing a 16-month course in 13
months fought a lot I had a really good
two different Jiu Jitsu schools I
trained out up there great partner named
Keith Paragon I train with him all the
time he lives up in Del Mar now he's
broken too now so we can't train but we
talk about how awesome we used to be to
each other and uh you know I would be I
have to say it because he's going to
love this but you know we actually had a
tournament and we were in the finals
together and
um when I tell the story I talked about
how bad I beat him but it was a zero to
zero and they gave me the nod and to
this day I have it over him so it's a
good thing to say
and uh and so I left there and they're
like hey you're going to go over uh over
in join team three on deployment I'm
like cool I landed there and they're
like well let's push him out to our
station
August 2nd I ended up with you you know
and I don't remember the Arabic test you
gave me I do remember
yeah because what was it Seth had called
over and said he needed
um he needed a new another term well we
had 18 interpreters two would go outside
the wire one got shot so yeah two
platoons you need an interpreter so he's
like I need a Turpin I'm and I you
didn't even ask me I was like hey man I
can I can habla you want me to do it and
and uh you want me to tell you let's
have you tell the story no go ahead I
want to hear what you have to say let's
hear your your memory ever first okay oh
you get the last word I see how it did
so I'm like hey just let's just uh let's
practice and there was that we had moose
there was that he was a good terp he was
good great and uh he uh I was like okay
you said we'll say some words to him so
I started talking and then we're talking
back and forth I'm like hey you don't
know what we're saying why don't you say
the words and I'll translate them and
you can see how we do and you're like
okay so you're like hey tell those guys
to get down at the end of the street so
I'm like yeah yeah I'm I'm talking and
then in the middle of it you're like
wait they're shooting get them off and
I'm like
like I'm choking you know because you're
like in my face
you did I locked up and and I'll and
then uh and you look at me and you were
like fail
[Laughter]
turn to walk away and as I walk away
you're like your flight leaves are one
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah that's similar to how I remember it
yeah so we had you me and moose and we
needed a terp and somehow you got to me
and said like hey you know uh I I speak
Arabic like that's where I just came
from DLI and I was like okay well how
well do you speak and you're like well I
just graduated with a whatever whatever
would you two plus two plus or whatever
thing you have yeah yeah
you are super impressed by the way yeah
yeah
and so yeah I said you know tell him and
I was all metal like tell him hey we
need people to move down to the west
side of that building and you're like
durka durka durka yeah and I look at
moose and I go did he say and he's like
yeah he said it he said okay now tell
him this and he tell him to push up one
more building you're like durka durka
durka durka and he's like yup that's
what he said and I said tell him she's
fired tell him to get off that building
now
completely locked up bro you just you're
just like yo
I didn't even know you I'm like who is
this guy screaming I've met you for like
five minutes and you know that was the
day Markley was killed yeah so it was a
weird kind of somber man when you jumped
on me like that I was like
but you know like you could speak it
well enough and guess what you were
better than what we had which was
nothing yeah so low bar yeah so like go
grab your I remember saying go grab
your flight leaves in an hour or
whatever it was so that was uh that was
how it all kicked off
um
to
to the east side of ramadi you you ran
out on some Ops over there for a bit yep
and then you pulled me back for
something I can't remember what I think
we had like a reservist good dude and
you wanted me to bump him out let him go
get on some Ops yeah and so but I
bounced back forth between Corregidor
and actually you guys dealt me out to a
bunch of different teams like on that
one deployment I did opposite team two
four five and eight because sometimes
they'd be like hey we don't have a terp
and you'd be like hey I got one for you
he's I'll deal them to you so like I got
a lot of Ops in uh and when you guys
were home I stayed after that too so I
got I got I got to work with a lot of
different teams yeah that was a wild
that's a wild time for you to show up
for sure yeah not only showing up like
like look you showed up the day
Markley died General Brown visited that
day so like the I don't know if you you
might have even come on the same bird I
don't know no no I I had to I drove you
over there in a Humvee and I didn't know
how to drive a Humvee because you're
like hey and I was like oh my God
because back then they didn't teach us
didn't work up and so like they're like
hey you gotta take drugs so I had to win
around trying to find Humvee keys
because I'm like because I gotta be
ready make sure I had gas in it but I
couldn't find the keys I'm like freaking
out so finally I I asked somebody like
hey bro
the keys and they're like you idiot
so you did you didn't know about that
part but like you know but I made sure
we had all the gas he's like you're just
going across the street like I don't
care make sure the gas is full make sure
everything I clean the Humvee make sure
it's good and so we picked her you and I
picked up General Brown I drove you over
there and then I think you wrote with
somebody else I don't think that I uh I
don't think that I said because we
trained Jujitsu too you threatened me I
didn't threaten you I knew you were
gonna you know what I knew this was
going to come up but
what what that happened almost
immediately too right no well you like
called me in your office you're like
okay so what's your deal I'm like I
don't know what's your deal what do you
mean and you're like yeah Sports this
and we get into it and eventually you're
like you know oh you do Jiu Jitsu I'm
like yeah I've been training for a
couple years I'm a blue belt and you're
like oh so what's like your move and I'm
like I don't know like no you got
something you're good at I'm like well I
guess when we train you'll find out
that's what I said and now he's like oh
[Music]
let's go you know what's funny you told
me that exactly
yeah
I I heard another version of it that was
like a little bit like not quite because
let's face it look I don't know how you
actually said it we could probably
discuss how you act but when someone
says the words yeah well when we roll
you'll find out let's face it that's the
kind of thing you know like oh okay
let's see what's up we'll see and so uh
yeah but in my mind this is the this is
the the way I was thinking in my mind
was look I've been training with like
all the guys that are there none of them
are good at Jiu Jitsu so you show up and
I'm kind of stoked I'm kind of thinking
like I didn't feel that yeah I was like
dude like maybe you got some good moves
like hey I'm good at crucifix I'm good
at kamira what are you good at like
it'll be good to like learn whatever you
know and obviously I didn't give you
that Vibe because you're just like wolf
you'll find out and then
I think I was like okay cool go grab
your gear we'll go straight exactly I
was like working my train right now you
submitted me with this thing where you
put your head under my I called it the
fish I felt like I was a fish you put
your head under my chin and like
crushing my back and because I did great
against the other guys you know I was I
was doing pretty good against them and
yeah and then when you showed up yeah
yeah well you're you're you're a like a
solid Jiu Jitsu player you know what I
mean and you wrestled but I mean that
even at that time I was like I was good
you know yeah I mean
are you trying with Dean yeah yeah it
was a level that I was not did not know
existed I train on the East Coast yeah
there's a difference between East and
West Coast or Jiu Jitsu the Jiu Jitsu
here is insane when I traveled when I
traveled you know I I would travel and I
would do
I was only a brown belt you know but
like I trained the different schools and
I I would I call it catch and release I
wouldn't would never submit the
instructor never but like I'd catch it
I'd let go and they they knew they'd be
like and they'd be like okay
I just remembered this so we had this
like tent you know like a GP medium tent
and I went you know what brought Matt's
unemployment that's where but they
weren't messed they were like those like
foldy cheap things with like the vinyl
top yeah but I remember you were like
after we rolled you were not you were
like distraught you were super destroyed
you were distraught like what just
happened yeah I wasn't sure because I've
had not been manhandled like that and
like I rolled with you know what I
thought was some high-level guys and I
was like this is stupid yeah you were
like you like dude you're like that's
that's that's never really happened to
me you know when I was just like what
year was this 2002 no this is 06. oh
sorry
yeah yeah so you're nodding your head
Echo because you know like I
that in comparison of the rest of the
world at that time I was really good if
you compare me to the rest of the world
right now like the rest of the world is
better now because like the whole world
is better at Jiu Jitsu now everyone is
better now because everyone's better
because there's that much more knowledge
and learning going on yeah but at that
time
in the whole world I was better than I
am in the whole world right now yeah you
know what I mean so for you to that was
a level I had was not ready you hadn't
been there yet and like I was there all
the time because I'm training with Dean
and like I'm training with World Champs
out here all the time so yeah that was
you want to hear the ending part of the
story how he told it to me yeah because
he told me that story and then he had
his like additional input of like as to
tell me so he said that exact same story
so funny how you use the exact words
like oh so what what are your moves so
same story and then um when he got to
the part when he said um when you said
oh you know we'll find out on the mats
or whatever and he added
it didn't matter because I was just
gonna smash from the top that's what he
said wait how did I say it I'm just
gonna smash from the top like that's
what I said to you or what I said to me
yeah yeah like kind of like the story
was done and then you were telling me
but it didn't matter because I was just
gonna smashed from the top I remember
that story yeah but once you started to
smash the top it wasn't a waste of your
time so you went to the bottom because
I'm like okay he's gonna give me some
top I'll show him interestingly that's
where I got the term smash from the top
from you telling that story yeah
damn smash dude I was so stoked to have
somebody that knew like Jiu Jitsu to
train with I know that might it might
not have come off that way and feel that
way yeah yeah you also introduced me to
the 20 squat workout if you remember
that
bro we had that hell yeah I was like I'm
just going to do a workout okay come
here
what's the way you can do 10 reps with I
was like uh 225 I think okay do it
so I did it and I put it up and you're
like that was too easy to hold you back
he's like take a break push him away do
it again so then I did with 245 and you
were like
you can do it I'm like I can't do it
again
I'm fired up like imagine you know when
you're in the teams and you get like a
team guy that's like a young guy I mean
you're a young guy to me then right I
mean I'm like 35 years old you know I've
been in the teams for a long time and
I'm always stoked to have somebody
that's fired up to like train and lift
and like it's awesome to me like that's
not how I felt I have to say that
I've got to please I hope I know this
answer I just I just saw another young
officer that had joined us on deployment
who's now a captain yeah I know you're
talking about remember I put him in an
arm bar and then like and he's like no
I'm good and I cracked and you're like
bro I was like oh sorry but I know
you're talking about it has to do
something like
you know Hey sir do you do you have any
recommendations my my shoulders kind of
injured do you have any recommendations
and I was like yeah muscle ups because I
had rings I was like yeah I do muscle
ups do lots of muscle ups like just the
worst the worst advice yes oh there you
go good times but what I was saying is
it's crazy so you arrived there Mark had
just been killed like it's like you said
somber and yet at the same time we have
the the socom Commander coming in
General Brown uh
and and you know this was
we we were in so much
sustained combat that it wasn't like it
wasn't like oh my gosh someone got shot
it was like yeah
okay we had 32 dudes 16 purple hearts
three killed is that right I think
that's roughly what it was it's
something like that
um
but yeah it was a lot and
yeah for you to show up there that
definitely must have been did you hear
about what was going on prior to
arriving no I was a DLI oh that was
anything yeah the regular Navy for all
intents and purposes didn't know much
about the war going on as far as I know
they had individual augmenties they did
stuff over there but I think most of
them ended up in a big base somewhere
which is like a big piece of America
kind of right like oh you're in Iraq or
you're a ballroom Airfield and they're
salsa night and yeah you know yeah one
thing that I didn't really connect with
until we got home was
the guys they were reading our op-sums
right like at trade at they were I was
in Arabic school they were reading the
op sums in the morning like meeting like
this is what the guys
make sense like and so everybody well at
least like the West Coast guys that were
in trade at and talking to the because
we were in trade at then you're telling
the platoon that you're training you
know so that everyone kind of knew what
was going on so you were just coming in
out from nowhere I had no clue that's
freaking crazy I had no clue yeah it was
time to learn fast and I remember the
guys were moving so much faster than I
was I really felt that way because well
we came up and like I've you know I had
my age gear wasn't set up like you guys
was because I had her on my hips and it
needs to be on your chest because we're
riding in vehicles all the time and I I
just wasn't ready and
somewhere a couple weeks into it I
stopped noticing that everyone's moving
faster than me yeah you got kind of
caught up until I stayed the next group
and the team Five Guys came in and they
were moving slow and I was like oh it
was it was a weird thing to realize like
hey the speed of combat takes a little
bit of ramp up yeah and you know you
know when when the guys get hurt the
beginning of the deployment and the end
of deployment that's it I mean that's
the preponderance of it because guys
come in and they're ramping up and in
the end of deployment they get a little
complacent maybe or they're thinking
about home they're not fully dialed in
it's always those times and I think it a
lot of that happened and we got we had a
lot of gunfights so it happened
sprinkled throughout but in my
experience it's been the beginning and
the end what did you say so you went
over to Corregidor and you meet with
donor what's what what are you taking
with your milk people don't know stoner
I walk up and Stoner doesn't say hi or
anything you know because I got my bags
on my kit and I'm like hey I'm Jimmy May
and we're living in this bombed out
thing we called Full Metal Jacket
basically like blow a building up that's
where we're living in like some of the
walls were down I remember the army guys
had a cat and like the cat liked me so
they thought I stole their cat but it
was nice because the cat ate the mice
and it would sleep with me in there and
there'd be that guy's the seal stole our
cat like I didn't steal them to catch
anyway but so we're living in this it
was you had to wear a body armor over
because you got mortared daily they're
just dropping mortars in there and
especially during Sandstorm because like
our counter-attacked mortars was to get
some helicopters up or like or get some
ISR which is intelligent surveillance
reconnaissance or like some kind of
asset overhead that can like drop on the
guys dropping on us but when sandstorms
didn't work so every Sandstorm you know
you're getting mortared and we got
mortared all the time so you had to wear
body armor everywhere so I come walking
up in Stoners Like I'm like hey uh I'm
Jimmy and he's like hey here we were
Army acus you can go in there there'll
be a set and we shave our head gave me a
Clippers I was like okay
I shaved my head and put on my Army
ACU's and then I and then I walked into
the thing and uh
my guest was working in there and they
got me to work that was that was my
indoct so I didn't have a lot to say
other than that but I remember you kind
of gave you know that head that head
shake like after I shaved my head but
he's just like I feel like it was good
uh
so you end up like you said you're doing
Ops all over the place
um and how much Arabic are you speaking
a lot so I spoke because we have a
partner for us and if you have a bunch
of guys with automatic weapons who are
kind of on your team you should be able
to know what they're saying and so I was
pretty valuable for that and it's also
nice when you have a team guy because if
you know you're going to set the guys up
downstairs you have a turp you got to
spend another team guy down there to
walk around with the terp and do you
trust that interpreter I don't know what
about those conversations going on
around you do you know what's happening
so I had like widely a wider net of
situational awareness than what you
would have if you didn't have a team guy
down there because I can hear him
talking about us and you know the same
thing with the prisoners talking you
know I did a lot of interrogations and I
would use an interpreter for the
interrogation uh the battlefield
interrogation but they don't know that I
understand what's what's going on and it
was a super powerful thing you know yeah
to figure out what exactly they were
saying
yeah I remember you told me too I had a
I had written an email to the Commodore
I still have it I gotta get it I gave
you a copy of it I gave you a copy it
was hanging in my cage I gave you I told
you about it and I made you a copy and I
gave it to you and it was it was about
it was about uh Hey because at the time
they were trying to get seals through
training is it that one yeah yeah
they're trying to get more seals too and
they're like you got to get more numbers
but you can't like if Echo if I had you
sit in that chair for five and a half
days it would suck dude like your feet
would be swollen now add on 200 miles of
running and carrying a boat and a log
and being cold and wet add all that on
there you know and so we just no matter
how you water it down we can't get more
guys through and then you came up over
the top of like don't make it easier
make it harder he's like he's like we
need more he goes we need a bigger tail
not more teeth yeah it was like so give
don't have seals do non-seal jobs and
man I've been spouting that for the rest
of my career like you know what why do I
got you counting columns why do I got
you fixing guns let's have you assault
and do what you need to do because at a
Fortune 500 company that top engineer
you're paying he ain't sweeping the
ground right he's not doing stuff he's
not paid to do I'm like have these seals
focus on that and then I'll add the tail
on the back so I thought that was pretty
wise and I hung it up but I don't know
yeah that so the Commodore was like a
friend of mine and a great guy and uh he
had sent out a like kind of in all hands
like or whatever leadership email like
Hey we're looking at you know ways that
we can grow the force and blah blah blah
and I just responded all hands because I
also you know was kind of halfway
through deployment and just that's the
that was the truth like you could see
that
the seals needed to be freaking awesome
guys like they needed to be tough like
everything you just said like oh show up
here put your gear on and go out and get
in gun fights that's what's gonna happen
for the next you know however long
you're here for you're not gonna have
good Chow it's gonna fall from the sky
yeah you know it's like that was
that was the time I said to myself oh
this is what all that training that we
go through this is why because someone's
got like you just said like who's gonna
be able to pick someone up and carry
them out uh when they get shot
who's going to run out into gunfire and
carry some out when they get shot who's
gonna stay up for 48 hours to make sure
that we're ready to go do like it is it
is what it is for a reason and all the
time like like when I got sleep it's on
the way to the op like if I had a calm
guy and like you know we set up a pro
word so so you know we're at and I'm
like hey bro I just need to sleep for
like 40 minutes so on the on the bird if
my calm guy is good and lots of times
I'm working till the last minute the
guys would throw my stuff in the truck
you know and not so I'm trying to line
up the assets like you got to go hurry
so I run in I jump in there and they're
briefing me on a lot of things that you
might think I'm running but you know
these guys set me up I trust them I know
I got a good point man I know I got a
good Chief and they're squaring me away
on the way because I got to set up all
of our like permissions you know through
the through the different layers of
command and the battle space owners and
everything so
yeah yeah the the the training is how it
is so yeah when the Commodore reached
out to all hands like hey you know what
can we do to to get more people through
it's like no give us more left we don't
care we don't need more seals we need
more support people to make this stuff
happen 100 and make sure that we're
getting the best freaking hardest guys
for lack of a better word look smart and
cable and all this other stuff you need
dudes that are just hard like
mentally hard dudes and buds produces
that
for the most part no it does it does
yeah uh
so you're doing Ops all over the place
um
we're getting towards the end of our
deployment and and that's when uh you
know September 29th
you were you were actually with stoner's
element which was like a couple blocks
away yeah we were probably about 350
yards away so like the the plan is to
have two mutually supporting sniper
OverWatch positions and mutually
supporting means that we can look around
there to make sure no one sneaks around
there around their base of their house
and we they can do the same for us but
it was really hard because we had to be
on the edge of what was called L block
at the time and they had some army guys
dude some 18 year old army dudes running
concertina wire across route farook in
the middle of the day I'm like I mean
that's crazy because are we insert at
night no one attacks us at night but it
was crazy that those guys were doing I'm
like I don't know what Japan these guys
but dang that's that's like some World
War II jump out of the trench I mean I
don't know that's a hard that's a hard
bar to get to but I did not think they
were going to make it and so we were up
on top of these roofs we're supposed to
shoot the guys from this one angle and
there was a bad mosque and uh I say a
bad Moss because I can understand what
they're saying of the speakers and so
when they say things like hey come give
blood in Arabic that means come in here
they arm up they get a plan and then and
then or they they get their weapons
stowed and they leave with the plan they
grab their weapons and then they go so I
know this is happening I can hear it
over the loudspeakers and so I'm like
hey guys get ready you know it's getting
ready to go and sure enough we've been
in a pretty good fight all day long uh
down on their end they've killed two
we'd killed one
I think our guy was a foreign fighter
because when we hit him someone ran out
and stole his boots and that was it
because like you know usually if they're
going to drag them out then maybe okay I
should probably shoot that person too
there's some Rules of Engagement and
escalation force that has to happen that
we abide by straight up but that being
said the fact they just stole his boots
means I think it was probably a foreign
guy and the body was there for a pretty
long time so then as this fight's going
and escalating
um I was on glass we had these
periscopes you couldn't stick your head
over the wall but you or through a
window but you put this Periscope above
and I remember this the house program
this guy named was Otto and he was a
good dude and I felt bad for him because
we were we went to use his house a lot
because it was a nice sniper range
a nice good line to shoot right in that
really bad area but when we left the bad
guys would come in and beat him up and
beat his family up and he would always
be like please don't leave and I'm like
dang bro I'm sorry man like I can't stay
he's like you know they're gonna come
and he even set up an American toilet
for us where he had like a chair he cut
a hole in that would sit it because you
know they have a hole in the floor so I
felt for that dude and I know Stoner did
too Stoner always gave him a bunch of
money of his own money been like hey I
know they're gonna steal and Break Stuff
take some money he always gave him some
money
but I was on glass when that thing blew
and you know that guy Mike asked that
came over the loudspeaker met it was
he's one of the hardest dudes I know I
don't think you'd argue with that his
voice was pretty broken I could tell oh
no this isn't good you know and and
Stoner was like Hey get the Iraqis let's
go and so the first three guys ran out
in the street I was trying to get the
Iraqis I couldn't they wouldn't come I
had the guy by the front of his front of
his plates and it was like trying to put
a cat in a bathtub man he had his hands
out on the side of the door and I'm
yanking and finally I I turned we left
our like our breaching tools and stuff
there because we had a lot to do so we
left like our hulies and our sledges and
our backpack we just had door night
vision on second line and just went out
there and I ran out there and Stoners
Like
he's like hey where are the Iraqis I'm
like they ain't coming he's like tell
him to come I'm like I can't
and so now we're already in a pretty
good scrap things are going bad two of
them did come with us uh Jamil and they
did come with us oh which
we knew them they were good people
anyway we started scrapping our way up
and then you talked about Benny grabbing
that gun that was Mikey's gun he grabbed
and uh the I was laying next to Tommy D
and uh there was like maybe a we're on
one side of the street the other
elements on the other side and probably
like a 12 inch high pile of rubble and
I'm we're pinned down there's like a
light post next to us and we were just
ping bullets are just flying and we
you're just laying as flat as you
possibly can I'm trying to reload my
magazine and I remember thinking like
gonna go from here and then I heard that
big gun light up and I was like
uh-oh but I'm like oh all sudden there
wasn't pinging around us anymore you
know like all the Spalding of the
concrete wasn't hitting him so when I
heard that I looked up and I saw him I
saw him holding that gun like just no
strap no nothing just at the at the
shoulder shouldering that big weapon and
just laying it down which probably the
most important covering fire of my
entire life and uh we got up and we just
we made it to the house underneath that
that uh that covering fire and uh as I
came up the way that the roof was there
was a center-fed uh a stairwell so you
came with a Miller roof and you could
see right what happened you know uh my
guess was blowing up in his feet because
he was laying down when he caught the
blast and then uh Mikey Mikey Mansour
was just bleeding up in man Benny not
only he did before he did that what took
him too long he was patching everybody
up like you know how it is when guys are
bleeding you never have enough gauze
doesn't matter what he made it work that
dude he's a man like he patched
everybody up so I but Mikey was bleeding
terrible and so like I rolled him over
and I I like swiped down his chest to
see what to see what I had because it
was just like a blood and gore and I
just saw holes and they filled back up
with blood and I was like and he was
kind of making this quickly noise so I'm
like okay I think he's going to live I'm
not a medic you know and uh it's stoner
stoner was a good combat leader
he looked at me he just said get Mikey
that's all he said and then he grabbed I
think he grabbed Mike S and kind of had
him on his hip because Mike kind of
hobble and then the other guys and you
know what you and I had this big
conversation when we met later on where
I just couldn't stop talking remember I
was just running my mouth and I remember
you just sat and listened and you know
it was about this because I felt really
ashamed I couldn't you know you see me
around Mikey's family like
I I just feel so you know like
like I let him down you know
um I had him as I carried him as far as
I could he was not a huge dude but he's
like 200 pounds you know and then you've
got probably another 60 80 pounds of kid
on both of us and uh at some point I
couldn't carry him anymore because we
couldn't get out the front and the Brads
wouldn't come that way of course they'll
get blown up I'm not saying anything bad
about those guys because they were our
brothers they weren't supposed to get us
anyway and uh we pushed down a wall like
a little uh
a wooden fence like a dog ear fence we
push it down it went out came out right
on Route farook and those guys were way
ahead of me I couldn't carry him anymore
because I just ran out of juice and I
was dragging him so I'm dragging him
through the street his his uh clothes
are shredding and we're getting to the
Brad and there's bullets hitting and the
guys are like yelling at me like hurry
hurry we're trying to close the door and
like I got in there and then you know my
guest came and talked to me once uh when
I was EXO Buds and I kind of was I kind
of apologized because I I checked out
for a minute like as a ramp went up I
was like I was so so tired you know how
we say that oh he's I was so tired and
and uh Mike is he's bleeding he's
sitting kind of funny because he's got a
bunch of frag in his body and he's like
dude
CPR I was like and then I kind of
snapped back on so I got to do CPR and
you know as you you do the chest
compressions stuff's popping and
cracking CPR is not a gentle sport you
know and then back then it was 15-2 now
it's 30 and zero but I did my 15 I tried
to blow in and I could see you're
supposed to look for the rise and follow
the chest I can see bubbles come out of
the holes and I'm like does that count
as one I don't know and he like at one
point threw up in my mouth and I was
just like I don't I don't know if I'm
doing it right and then you know we did
that all the way till we got to cop Aid
which was like the little medic Outpost
they had set up and then
um I had fired like I fired some rockets
and stuff so my ears were kind of like I
couldn't really hear it was this big
roaring thing and the Medics were
talking to me trying to bark at me
because uh Mikey and Doug had got their
name tapes kind of blowed up a little
bit and they couldn't have
uh what the blood type was and they're
sitting there trying to ask me and I
remember I couldn't understand what
they're saying and then I'm like who are
you talking about and then and they were
like washing because I had all this
Blood I'm either washing it off with
their water hose or spraying me and I'm
looking at them and uh and and when that
backtrack when that Bradley door opened
the first two dudes just stuck their
head in there was at the time uh Colonel
Clark remember that dude I think he's a
general now he absolutely first dude him
and major Womack I mean that little
crack their heads in there and you know
he called us frog man he was like frog
man he's like get out of there we got a
Medicare I'm like all right you know but
uh good dudes full of respect for them
all the best yeah yeah anyway and it
turned out they needed no kind of blood
type these guys were in their names and
so like I don't know why I think maybe
they morphine them and they couldn't get
it I don't know why but I kind of came
to enough to give them that and then
then you showed up I don't know when
right before it was maybe a little bit
later but I remember I just couldn't
stop talking and you were just kind of
sat there and listened to me and yeah I
really struggled with
um did I do things right for Mikey you
know and I did if a better guy was there
and I actually went and talked to the
doctor that worked on him I came in like
I know I just once want to hear like did
I mess this up you know and he showed me
an x-ray it looked like a bunch of fuzz
and he's like see this this is his heart
and these are pieces of the you know and
I was like he goes there's nothing you
could have done and so he told me what I
needed to know but I know that I didn't
I wasn't up on my medical care like I
could have done like so anyway the point
was he told me what I needed to hear it
felt good
I don't know you know maybe if there was
a better guy up there it would have
worked out better but that's that's how
it worked out no I mean uh all the all
the doctors said the same thing you know
like
he was mortally wounded from the moment
of you know and um
it was actually it was actually uh
Colonel Clark that called me told me
what was going on and he he told me like
they're they're doing CPR right now and
I just knew like yeah CPR is not a good
sign to be doing
um
and you know I I was trying
explain to people like that it wasn't
over either like you still had to go
back out in the field to get the Iraqis
get the gear that you guys left behind
um you know I remember talking to Stoner
he's like I'm going back out right now
you know like that kind of thing yeah
and so I didn't go with him he went
without me because I was with those guys
like I jumped in the Brad with those
guys to show them back so he went back
and got the gear and stuff in the Iraqis
yeah because we don't leave gear yep
um
beyond that was September 29th we ended
up I mean you guys still did
more Ops than that oh yeah yeah and you
know I I teach this now and I teach more
detail for what I do with the with the
the SEAL Teams but you know
I always taught like about minimum force
and what you should have because we
didn't have a medic you know our medic
took around
earlier so we didn't actually have a
medic on that op and we talked about
minimum force requirements and stuff
like that and uh I used to teach like
after that you know I knew about Min
force and I never did it again when
there was a guy that was on off with me
he's like no we even started it up like
three weeks just three of us I'm like oh
yeah I learned it now but uh yeah we
were still working I mean yeah it's like
being on the mat right if I stop you're
still going yeah the same thing happened
we had the fight wasn't going so we kept
going yeah that was a a different
definitely a dynamic for that deployment
that I think was
for us anyways for me you know
especially growing up in the 90s in the
teams it was like in the 90s in the
teams your your mindset was you're gonna
go do One op somewhere um like that's
what you're gonna do like one big
mission You're Gonna Go Rest save the
princess or slay the dragon or whatever
and when it's over it's over
and
you know like ramadi was not it was like
it's not like you just said the enemy's
still going like they don't care they
live there they live there they don't
care what's happening they're they're
going to keep going and you know even
even at like the Seal Team level
the thought of like oh replacements
right you know like we didn't there was
no one ever talked about hey like once I
took over trade at you know I would talk
to the CEOs I'd be like hey what is your
replacement plan for if you lose three
guys from a platoon of 16 guys that's a
huge hit and who did you lose did you
lose a jtac did you lose a Corman did
you did you did you lose one of your
senior enlisted guys like
we didn't really talk about that we just
didn't and and that's another reason why
you need to have you know at least
troop-wide ttps the techniques tactics
and procedure procedures but team-wide
for TPS and probably community-wide
because like you know we're like we
don't have doctor and we kind of do our
own thing but you know in the
platooniers course I teach away you know
when I took over the course I used to
teach and I'm like hey you got to be
able to plug and play with another
platoon like I'm Afghanistan deployment
I took in half another platoon and you
know they if they couldn't operate with
us that they used different things it
wouldn't work so you got to have that
interoperability and I think that
probably spawns some of that and I
definitely learned it at that point yeah
but uh yeah we really tried to push that
and you know we had like a
you know we had like a battle book about
casualties right like if you have a
casualty here you're gonna do you're
gonna you know shut down the radios
you're gonna do this you're gonna
contact these people like there was a
there was an administrative protocol to
fennel yeah timeout you need you're
still in a fight yeah but there wasn't
there was two things that there wasn't
there wasn't like a combat like okay
where's Replacements what are we doing
what are we doing here and also like
what does it do to the team
like what do you do with a guy that's
now horrified what do you do with a guy
that is now feels like oh this was my
fault or I should have done this like
just the same like everyone's gonna have
those thoughts I should have done this
if I could have done this different and
how you know how do you walk through
that what are you supposed to do what's
The Grieving period how long do you take
off do you take off short time law so
for me it was a lot of like
trying to figure this out and honestly I
got a lot of it from about face from
Colonel David hackworth you know about
what I would kind of reflect on what key
would do and that's kind of what I did
um
but it's you know you know Mark was the
first
seal killed in Iraq you know there was
no
uh lessons learned that I had recovered
from somebody else so and it's the same
thing for the rest of the rest of the
guys in the task unit and I have a
perspective on that I definitely have an
opinion on that especially after you
know I got hit
November 10th I ended up getting hit
after you guys go home and
um
you know this is true I don't know if
you know about this this is exactly what
happened I I end up you guys went home
team five came in I'm like hey
I speak Arabic you guys should probably
keep me and they're like yeah we don't
have anybody so we'll stay so I'm
staying at Team house deployment great
dudes they showed up and uh you know we
got in a pretty we're supposed to do
this clear this market area the malab
you know what the malab is that was it
so lava means play the M sound at the
beginning makes a verbal noun which
means place you play so it's the arena
and we're supposed to be sniper
OverWatch as the Iraqi Army clears this
whole market for like three to five
hours
that's the plan we insert at night no
one mess with the night we get in there
we can't find two good spots so we end
up on the same house and the Iraqi Army
shows up for like three to five minutes
seriously they showed up and they made a
u-turn and I'm like hey man I've got
I've got their comms on a little thing
so I can kind of listen I'm like What's
Happening like
I think do I don't understand the schema
maneuver and like Nick know they left
and so now we're getting we're stuck and
the plan was for them to go out and grab
a big bite so they grab a big bite
around circus area then we fall into
their perimeter and then we we leave
with this like 400 band of Iraqis and
their Humvees and everything and that's
how our ex-fill plan
well now you know I mean we've got a lot
of as much as we can carry but if you're
in a gunfight with the whole city you
know you you can't sustain that so it's
about 11 o'clock and we're like I don't
know how much more we can do this so the
call is made like hey let's call those
let's call these guys to come get us and
they already told they can't get us they
said they're not okay we cannot Expo you
there
because the IED threat but they're like
we're coming anyway so the plan was for
me to bounce around corner I had a lot
of Rocket left so I was going to hit
this house with law rocket and then
inside of me the 60 which is like a Mark
48 which is like a belt-fed machine gun
762 100 round belt he's going to open up
but and I'm gonna run it I'm going to
run around the corner from there and
then the Brads are going to come and
we're supposed to run next to the Brads
and run all the way back to cop Eagle's
Nest remember that where that water
tower was we're supposed to run back to
there so it's not a super long way but
what's it like I don't know 350 yards
500 yard dash so we're going to do that
I go outside I go open up that rocket
because it's like it's the kind that
opens up like you know like you see in
the movies that open up that's what it
is it's actually not a very big rocket
um but I got to shoot it thing blows up
in my face like I don't know if I hit a
wire if I did it wrong I am an officer
it could have been possible but it blew
up right in my face so I'm waiting for
the gun to pick me up I hear another
crazy explosion not sure what's going on
I pick up my my M4 I start pepper in the
house waiting for the 60 to pick me up
they don't pick me up I come back around
the corner guys are running out I'm like
what's going on they're like hey the
Brads got hit
that was the explosion I heard so we
gotta go
and so we are just trying to get out
we're throwing smokes and I'm running
down running down around the as I Round
the Corner around the stadium there's a
house set back about 200 yards opens up
with a with their version of a belt fed
machine gun the 60. it's called a what
do they call that PKM yeah PKM it just
doesn't have disintegrating link but
it's the exact same thing so it's a 762
by like 56 right pretty good I have
three rounds hit me as I come around the
corner
I I was carrying my rocket tube because
we don't leave gear behind right I mean
don't
I heard what undc talked about
Afghanistan and I was yelling at the
radio when you guys did that on your
podcast because
I have a spent rocket I'm not going to
lose you know what I mean and yet we
leave billions of dollars in Afghanistan
I was yelling at the rate I was like so
mad anyway I come around the corner and
my hand was back so I had one round hit
my Camelback hose one round go through
my chest and the other one go through my
backpack it kind of Spun me around I
fell under a burnout car and then he was
thought I was dead and my lost
Consciousness for a minute when you
think you did you probably did for a
minute because I kind of hit the thing
and then uh he had a thing like a laser
on like a little a jersey barrier you
know what a jersey barrier is like oh no
it's like a those little concrete
barriers between like traffic going
opposite directions like on a highway or
yeah construction site they got like a
little three foot tall four foot tall
little like the cement yeah yeah the
cement thing yeah it's like a jersey
bear so they all jump behind that thing
he's drilling that thing and then like
I figure out what's going on I can feel
that I'm bleeding I end up I'm like I
still got a couple more rounds in my
magazine so I emptied everything I had
through that window pretty sure I got
him
um not positive didn't do a BDA a battle
damage assessment didn't do that but
when I was done everyone was had run
back so I'm like oh I guess I'll run
back and I ran back and uh the medic who
is now an elected official awesome dude
I got back to Eagle's Nest on my cake
guys I think I got shot they're like I'm
pretty sure so I opened up my plates and
he puked right on me like threw up right
on me it's like bro
I don't think that's useful it kind of
wiped in the big beard he wiped his face
and then they put a piece of hydrogel on
it hydrogel is the stuff we use to stick
explosives to a door it's not like an
absorbent thing it's like a how do you
describe hydrogel Draco
glue uh on a piece of plastic piece of
plastic maybe they just took it on my
chest so I'm still bleeding why'd he
throw up because it was gross he's a
medic I don't know but he's we're good
friends like we're really good friends
and maybe he just didn't like seeing his
buddy get shot but oh damn I don't know
why I threw up yeah but he said he sent
me a picture of it on like Christmas
2014. I'm at dinner I'm like bro give a
brother a heads up before you send me a
picture yeah just to give everyone like
you got if that's not the luckiest one
of the luckiest shots to get shot the
way you got shot was like one of the
luckiest possible ways to get shot but
yeah I was running at a full Sprint
through it through a solid beam of ammo
and the and the bullet hit like
basically went through like your chest
like just like your pack flesh yeah like
which is crazy to be able to survive you
know that's like that's like the guy
moves his sight uh a millimeter uh
you're dead yeah or if I'm a little bit
slower on my 40 yard dash yeah so you
got this I mean what amounts to
essentially a bad flesh wound but not a
horrible flesh room I mean you were
running around after you got shot so
yeah just so everyone knows what the
shot was it was it was from the side it
went right through like your Peck yeah I
had soft body armor and so he said it
hadn't been hit with a smaller round it
might have broke the trajectory and
would have went in my ribs or something
but since there's such a big heavy round
it cooked right through my soft body
armor right behind my plates didn't hit
him and went right through and it left a
burn mark across the other side so it
went through my right pick and my left
pick so I got like two little holes here
yeah so it came out in uh what he called
grazed your other pack yeah yeah I had
this little burn mark and they gave me
when I got there they gave me like a
pipe cleaner and I had to like put it
through one side and kind of floss it
dude I wanted to throw up I'm like all
right so gross and then I had like you
know those squeezy bottles like football
players have so they can squeeze through
there I had one of those and I had to
irrigate it they called it where I had
to squirt it and then like like push
that little like that's the pop noise
I'm not supposed to make but look at
those pop pop the little blood clot out
of there and I had to do that for a
couple days and then uh but I was
so this is
it gets weirder so I go there I get to
the hospital they take they have to take
chest or x-rays that's what they have to
do and they're like
hey you uh good news you didn't hear
anything important you're good to go and
that's why they put that that hydrogen
because it's an occlusive bandage
because what could happen is if you poke
a hole in your lung even a small lung a
small hole as I breathe out that Air
instead of coming out of my mouth it
comes out of my lung and it it fills up
my body cavity and it collapses your
lung called a tension pneumothorax and
then that you end up like dying from
that unless they poke a hole in you and
actually the medic wanted to poke a hole
oh just in case I'm like I don't think
so bro he's like no no I'm the medic I'm
like no you're not going to poke a hole
in my chest like I think I'm good like
we got a little argument about it so
then I go there we're good to go now I'm
pretty angry
like I'm angry and I'm also embarrassed
and ashamed because I'm not supposed to
be getting shot man you know I mean like
I don't I don't know that's just how I
felt and so I was really pretty
distraught so I walked out I wrote CG
for cricketer on my hand because that's
how the helicopters work back then
remember and I had a beard and a cool
gun so nobody asked me a question and I
got on and I flew to cop age as close as
I could get and I got out of cop Aid
and uh I was running down Route Michigan
going towards Michigan is like the most
IED route since the Ho Chi Minh trail I
think that's how they said it now we're
running down that at night trying to get
back so I'm probably like I don't know
was it three quarters of a mile from
craigdore from cop a roughly and I see
the boys pull out onto the street and so
I break out my infrared chem light so
you can only see with night vision I pop
it and I make the little bud saws and
they pull over and it was the same medic
because they're going to get some Iraqis
to go up and he's like he's like what
are you doing I'm like I'm coming back
he's like it's Jimmy I was like oh yeah
hell yeah Houston Texas you know he's
like hell yeah and uh I can probably say
his name yeah he's elected official
yeah okay Morgan Latrell so he's like
hell yeah come on and so they called in
and they're like hey we got we got Jimmy
here like negative he's at the hospital
and uh we're going to pick him up and
they're like nope he's right here what's
going on up and we're going on off and
they're they're like okay we'll handle
it later and that's and so I went on I
went out and uh worked with them for
another couple weeks until December 10th
when uh you know Elliot got blown up and
Joe November 19th
I'm sorry December test yeah it was
that's a different date sorry so never
November test when I got shot and then I
I went home with uh Elliot Miller and
Joe yep yeah yeah those guys got
um really messed up yeah leaving uh
leaving an OverWatch position and we're
supposed to have Elliot on at some point
um so Elliot let's go
we're gonna make it happen yeah
um
and then so you fooled those guys those
guys home wounded yeah I flew back with
them right around Thanksgiving I think I
did Thanksgiving with Joe in the
hospital Elliot wasn't really very uh he
couldn't really talk too well he was
really really messed up and he ended up
uh we had a as we were dropped as a play
and gain elevation I'm not a doctor but
he was up coding and like I remember
this nurse was like messing within the
flight crew was like you need to sit
down well we're trying and she's like no
and I was like I love you like hell yeah
like she's like nope I'm staying at work
and she did she stayed and worked on him
and uh you know he had like an SUV worth
of medical equipment on his bed and she
was just working all of it and they were
trying to get her to like when they land
and take off and she just wouldn't do it
she stayed there and worked so mad
respect for that lady God bless her and
then uh you know we had we end up having
to fly lower than we wanted to and we
ended up dropping we dropped off Joe at
Bethesda and then we sent I think we
sent La down to San Antonio for the burn
center he was pretty blowed up and then
uh you know I land in San Diego so I'm
like you 36 hours of a pretty major
gunfight and you know my wife had left
me and went back with the kids and I the
ambulance drove away
I have any place to go I went to the
team I think I went to Danny's and then
I think I slept in my cage sometimes and
I was just getting ready until because I
we were already in mid work up because I
missed the part of the workup I missed
the professional development part so we
were already starting unit Level
Training and so I didn't need a place to
live because you're gone most of the
time anyway and so that was kind of
where I I was at that time just living
in my cage kind of yeah and so now
you're a platoon Commander at Team three
yeah and you're in stoner's task unit
right I am yeah
yeah same same guys that I'd been with
before I remember seeing you the team
and you're like
hey did you get shot I'm like yeah like
the Trap or something you're good huh
I'm like yeah I think I'm good he's like
okay cool you train it I'm like yeah
I'll be training
[Laughter]
uh how's that work up
um
that was the one I did bad
um as the OIC that was probably my worst
performance in any platoon I've done and
uh you brought it to us it it it trade
it and I remember you you know that one
where we come down the canyon we you
guys killed all of us like we were all
dead and you left me alive to try and
solve problems and I just I wasn't doing
it and uh you know I I still remember I
was carrying like a person and a 60
because everyone had we could even fight
we were combat effective just running
down this thing like
I don't know Stoner was pretty upset
with me rightly so yeah you know uh when
I think about this whole story because
I've never really like thought about
your whole career like this before but
this is why that training was so
important because essentially you had
guys that had just not been in
leadership positions before and you're
an example like I really hadn't you
really hadn't been in an actual
leadership position I was a combat
interpreter right and so you learned
some really good lessons learned about
combat you learned about like how to
handle yourself but as far as like
maneuvering elements around and this was
very common in the Seal team and you
would come sit next to me and I'm
shooting and you're like what are you
doing and I'm like I'm shooting and
you're like you should make a call but
I'm like but I'm shooting because that's
what I do you know I had never been
leading and I remember you pulled me
aside you're like you need to sit behind
a bush with your gun pointing up in the
air looking around and I'm like that's
it's just I'm like that's ridiculous
like you know but it's right but at the
time I was just like bro well and it's
the same thing I realize this because
Leif and Seth were the same way Leif and
Seth were like when they got into my
task unit they they had both done
something similarly like they were in a
platoon where they got told hey keep
your mouth shut your new guy on
deployment they sat in the jock doing uh
PSD or whatever so they didn't really
actually
and this was so common in the teams that
you could be like a young officer you'd
never been in charge of anything before
and you definitely didn't get taught how
to do this stuff and so
that's why like that that training was
so important and you know what I do
remember is one time you guys were at uh
Urban Warfare and you guys were all
jacked up and I got done like debriefing
your platoon and stoner's all freaking
mad
and he goes Jimmy Scott come with me and
he this was still out at Fort Knox oh
yeah he wrote us up so he walks outside
and I follow he that calls you to
outside and he starts yelling at you
guys
and
you know you guys are like Roger Roger
and you said get the hell out of here
and he walks away and I look at him and
I go hey bro
how many times did I yell at you when
you worked for me
and he like you saw the look on his face
he was like oh because I never
yelled him I never yelled at life and
you know I think he had a neck brace on
at that time too remember no he did that
was the neck brace oh he might have
because I remember he yelled out with
his neck bracelet yeah yeah that might
have been it
but it was one of those things where he
was like oh yeah and it was like Hey man
if your guys
if you think you need to yell at your
guys that means you haven't trained them
right that means they're making mistakes
they need to learn not get yelled at
like I can guarantee you you know that's
like when I was saying earlier when you
showed up and this is like I I would
meet a young again I'm not trying to
sound like I'm an old man but I had been
in the SEAL Teams for a longer time than
you and I could see that you want to do
a good freaking job at what you were
doing like to me that's just like the
most that's all you could want man all I
ever wanted from
a guy was like they want to do a good
job they want to do a good job and
they're tough and I remember actually
there was a little uh uh uh political
movements this is during our work up
during my work up with tasking the
Bruiser and they were like thinking of
moving some of the officers around and
like maybe they're gonna move Stoner or
something like this and they're gonna
give me a different officer and the Ops
officer pulled me and he's like hey you
know we could make this adjustment and I
was like I was like no I don't I don't I
don't want I want these guys I want life
and I want Seth
and they're like well you know these
other guys might have some more
experience and I was like what I want is
guys that are tough and guys that want
to do a good job
and I said Seth and Leif are tough and
they want to do a good job so when I met
you I was like oh this guy's tough and
he wants to do a good job and so when
you were in your workup with Seth dude
you wanted to do a good freaking job you
know like of course and you're tough
give me that all day long I don't need
to yell at you and that was my point to
Seth was like bro that guy both you and
Scott you guys wanted to do a good
freaking job if you screwed something up
it's just because you didn't know what
to do at that particular moment all you
want to do is learn so let's teach them
not let's not yell at him and he's like
Roger so
yeah I didn't know about that
conversation but I definitely you know
the learning curve was Steep and years
later when I came back as a troop
Commander I was much much more ready to
go there and I spent a lot of time with
my officers my junior officers and uh
you know I did a lot of work with them
and then I took another platoon on so
the way that the seal workup is it
started off a professional development
six months then unit Level Training six
months was with Jocko ran and then
you've got at the end you've got TJ at
task group Integrations the last six
months we get all your assets well they
gave me another platoon that I didn't go
through my work up with me and uh
actually uh it was Bobby Ramirez who uh
killed himself the weekend after my
retirement actually great guy
tragedy truly
um but he he came with me as my as one
of my season he's like he's like hey man
all this stuff that you're teaching my
jails because I brought his jails I'm
like hey I do jail development once a
week he's like will you teach me I'm
like
his true Commander didn't teach him that
he didn't know how to do Ground Force
Commander Stone now his chief was a
badass it was uh bo you know that guy oh
yeah yeah and that made it for him but
good on Bobby for having that kind of
like humility to be like hey you're can
I sit in with the jail so here he is an
OIC and a prior enlisted guy at that so
he's probably got you know six platoons
with experience and he's like hey I you
know I need to learn how to do this and
that's to your point like we never
really taught him how to do that and I
didn't know it either
and I I failed that work up pretty bad I
feel like like I mean I know that Stoner
was pissed yeah well also everybody kind
of failed that work up but by the time
you go everyone would learn like there
would be a steep learning curve but the
shit's not rocket science either like I
would tell you like one time like hey
dude you don't want to do that you'd be
like Roger you wouldn't do it anymore
like or hey you might want to think
about this and you do it like
so yeah everyone gets their ass kicked
and
as and 90 of guys go dude I just got my
ass kicked what what do I need to do
better 10 of guys go I got my ass
character it's because the training
sucks or because my Chief sucks or
because my new guys are what if they
just blame other people and they're
never getting better and they get fired
but yeah your normal kind of learning
curve especially again I never really
connected your whole
leading up to this like you didn't have
like a true assistant platoon Commander
you know what I mean where you were like
okay you're gonna run this squad and
you're gonna run through these I ads and
you're gonna run through the house or
whatever you're going to be doing this
you were kind of like carrying this
carrying a pig and doing travel claims
which is not great officer development
man so I hope that we started doing a
better job you know and that was my main
effort that's why I went to trade it the
reason I went to trade at when I got I'm
glad you went there that was good it was
good good for that thing that's the
reason because I knew that we had
learned I knew that I I knew that what
life and Seth knew on deployment I was
teaching them while we were in work up I
knew that and I was like who's going to
teach these guys you're on your sixth
diploma by the time right that was my
seventh okay seven so it's like 100 at
about at about third three three
deployments you're kind of a Jedi like
that that's when the Jedi thing kicks in
I think but and then after it's
completely different because the first
one you don't know what's going on two
you think you know what's going on but
you don't three man the blinders come
off you have some excess capacity I can
tell what you're about to do you know
what I mean if you screw up no big deal
I'll just play off that and fix it it's
about that seven year mark that it
really hits I think that's my opinion
and what what really helped me out a lot
was I when I was in E5 I was in training
cell at Seal Team one and I was a single
young guy and guess what that meant
nothing better to do I taught CQC land
Warfare combat sir I did everything I
did everything and so now I'm watching
these things and I could see like oh
that guy doesn't that guy shouldn't be
over there oh that guy's on his weapon
too much or that that platoon
Commander's not making a call and so I
through teaching it got to look at
things from a detached perspective and
that's really by the time I got to team
two now one ends into team two I just
got done teaching this stuff and I
wasn't like oh I know everything but I
was like I can I I know I need to take a
step back I know I need to look around I
know I know you don't need to be
shooting my weapon I know I need to keep
things simple I know we need to cover
and move for each other right I know we
need to focus on certain priorities I
know we need decent like I knew those
things yeah and so it was very lucky for
me and so then when I got done with that
deployment to ramadi I was like There
Was You Know The Admiral said where do
you want to go yeah and I was like I
want to go to trade at because I didn't
say why I think he knew but I wanted to
make sure these lessons got passed on
because because also the Battle of
ramadi wasn't over when we left you know
I mean you got wounded Joe and Elliot
got wounded I mean that was still hard
fighting I was like I don't know when
this is going to be over so all these
guys all my friends that are about to
get in another platoon and roll back
over there they need this training like
I need to make sure they have this and
that was what became my focus
um but you know like I said you you had
a little bit of a lack of knowledge but
as soon as you would get tightened up
you'd fix it and freaking kick ass I
mean that's that was pretty normal from
from my perspective like I said if
someone's arrogant
they would suck I think the bar came in
high for me they're like oh Jimmy just
come off the ramadi deployment he's
ready to go but uh so they came in
expecting me to know these things and I
really didn't because I was essentially
a combat interpreter for yeah most of
the time I really didn't do a whole lot
of leading on the battlefield to be
completely honest as an officer you're
supposed to be in from the front but I
was actually doing what my my Niche my
part in that Cog was that yeah and uh
you know I wasn't going to step on
stoner's toes or you know anybody else's
and how was so you had some challenges
during work up but like I said it was
normal I mean Stoner was stoked on
having you like 100
um and I'm talking like as you guys went
through and he'd be like oh yeah we
screwed this up I was like yeah but we
got it you know what I mean uh how is
that deployment so you guys go on
deployment yeah it was it was a
frustrating one because you know I just
came off that super kinetic deployment
and I got all the same kinetic guys that
want to go scrap it out and you know
what it just wasn't that it's like hey
man you can't shoot the wheels of
Engagement have changed you can't shoot
people for what you should shoot people
for and now you know we had to dial them
down a lot and then uh you know I had
Chris Kyle on that deployment and uh he
ended up you know he took around in uh
in solder City kind of yanked his helmet
off and I wasn't there with him he came
back with me and he was a he was a
different person after that
um you know I remember thinking the I
wanted to help him as best I could and I
did all the things I thought I could do
but he he really struggled um you know
at first it was kind of funny like oh
the legend it's about time who gets a
nickname like the legend in the teams
I'm coconut Jimmy whiskers that's not it
that's as good as I can get you know
whiskers I haven't heard that one yeah
that's a newer one because I got nine
lives I always land on my feet
and then eventually it went to gato and
then it's been whiskers yeah Jimmy
whiskers anyway
yeah
so yeah that that was pretty much a
non-kinetic deployment it wasn't totally
non-kinetic we rounded up 12 hvis high
value individuals so we had some Ops but
it wasn't like I mean I reloaded my mags
seriously probably multiple times a week
like because I'm shooting live rounds at
people every night and then on that one
it just wasn't quite that you know and
the appetite was more like let's try and
build this place and you have to you
know it's a shifting it's not you just
can't beat everybody up all the time at
some point you got to build some people
up and let them do their own beating up
and that was kind of the phase was in so
it was frustrating for those guys coming
off that deployment to realize like hey
it's not that kind of fight again and
you know I'm in the middle of that I'm a
pretty aggressive guy I think and so you
know I had to do some growing up there
too sure
so what what's your next job after that
one
so after that I went to Bahrain because
as an Arabic speaker I actually kind of
had it out with the XO we didn't
don't care much for this dude but we he
was the one to send me to the Pacific
next he's like hey you've got two
back-to-back tours in Iraq wait this was
the EXO at Team three yeah at the time
yeah and uh he was like you need to go
to the Pacific I'm like listen bro
nobody speaks Arabic about me it's
stupid to send me back there have me do
my true Commander here or my or task
unit Commander back then is what it's
called and he's like no he's like you
need to get well-rounded you're not
you're just you're so one-sided it's
going to be bad for your promotion which
I didn't care about I came in to go to
war and I know people like no you came
in to be an officer I'm like no I came
in to go to war that's what I came in
for so anyway we had it out and I was
like that's so stupid so he sent me to a
one-year tour in Bahrain to do J sets
which once again I'm like I'm going to
miss the whole War I was all frustrated
uh we didn't know it was gonna last 20
years back then I know I know you know
how everyone was like I can't miss the
war and I went over there and ran J sets
and actually for the same commanding
offshore team three that we had there
yeah okay he went over to uh to Bahrain
and actually we got along really well
over cool because at Team three I think
he was really nervous around me and yeah
I don't know he's a good man I think
well of him now he came out to my
retirement actually if you remember yeah
yeah but we worked together really well
down there and I definitely count him as
a friend in an ally now yeah
and you're just basically working a
bunch of setting up these exercises over
there and running things yeah yeah so I
think there's like 22 joint combined
exercise for training that's what a j
set is and then you know you you fly in
there you grab a platoon that's on
deployment that's not doing anything you
pair them up with the skill set they
want to learn and a lot of is like
showing up for the final ceremony I got
along super well with all the Arab
people because I speak Arabic and they
love it you know I got to go falcon
hunting with the bahraining royal family
and uh you know just it was an
interesting deployment my Arabic got
pretty tight I found a place to train
Jiu Jitsu down there and uh yeah they
had flown in a Brazilian who was good
and but then the the guys that ran the
thing was not very good he was a black
belt he you know how sometimes he'll
just pay for their black belt that's so
much happened because I was tearing him
up as a blue belt and then but his
Brazilian guy that was it was under an
alliance school I believe that Brazilian
guy would put me in my place pretty
quick I got to fight in Abu Dhabi I went
to I went and did a Jason over the ADCC
trials or just trained in no the Abu
Dhabi tournament I got the fight in that
tournament so like I went there for two
weeks and uh there was a jset going on
so I stayed there and trained there and
they had like 30 Brazilian black belts
Brazil like you know putting you in the
guad and grabbing your batch and you
know they were good and uh I it was
super fun to train with them because the
the locals didn't want to train Jiu
Jitsu and it was at the equestrian
center in in Abu Dhabi and I trained
there and then I stayed and I got to
fight in the Abu Dhabi I did six I did
six rounds I didn't make the medal round
as a I think I was fighting as a blue
maybe purple at that time that
definitely was blue and I don't know I
was fighting with him and I'm getting
knocked out by uh I didn't we lost my
points to a Brazilian but it was really
cool man like just getting a fight in
that term you fight all night you start
at 10 p.m and you fight all night
because it's like 130 degrees at night
there yeah yeah your Arabic must have
gotten freaking good yeah I was tired
yeah because my last memory of your
Arabic I know this is a good one was it
was it Mikey launchers Memorial so yeah
Mikey monsource Memorial
and we're at Camp Corregidor the guys
from the first the 506. yeah like it's
it's freaking heavy obviously
and the Iraqi Scouts yeah it was
Muhammad wanted to like have their guys
talk and put some word out
and so you were The Interpreter yeah
well so it was respect yes because
Arabic is a much more flowery language
and they have different levels of
respect which are different words and so
he would be like he'd be like you know
to use your durka durka and I'd be like
and respect and he'd be like durka durka
and I'd be like heavier deeper respect
I'm like super heavy
so I'm listening to this that's really
what it translates I'm listening to this
and you know
and I mean obviously it's like super
emotional but then I'm actually trying
to listen to like how Jimmy's doing up
there a little bit right and I don't
notice it at first but the guy's like
going on you know you see like after a
post-fife interview like the guy's
Russian or the guy's Brazilian and so
they're they're going on and on and on
and on and then The Interpreter will be
like he says he's looking forward to the
next fight you're like that didn't just
happen so the same things happen here
like this this guy Mohammed is up there
and he's talking you know he's talking
for like you know let's call it like 45
seconds and then Jimmy's like
they truly respected Mike and I'm like
okay cool and then it happens again and
he's like it was a deep respect and I
was like well then it happens again this
is like a seven minute speech which
Jimmy did in 17 seconds right so we get
done bro and I walk up tonight bro what
was that guy saying like you only
interpreted one word and I go he goes
well it's really complicated there's a
bunch of different words I go all right
bro well I I just know you're not ready
for like you win that's what you said to
me you're like you're not ready for the
U.N I was like all right because you
know I was I was what 36 hours out of
that gunfight too that wasn't super
stoked you know and Jack was just like
um
not ready for the U.N I'm not ready for
that U.N slot bro oh Jack
um
so you get done with this Bahrain gig
for a year and then next up you go out
to the east coast you go out to a team
on the East Coast yep yeah I go out
there and it's it's a kind of a big
selection process and uh I go all the
way through it and at the end they ended
up decided to put me and it was my own
fault I screwed up on one of the major
operations they were grading and they
decided to send me to a different
Squadron that I didn't want to go to and
uh not only did they send me to it
that's like hey you're going to deploy
on February 24th I'm like do you mean
tomorrow
am I deploying tomorrow they're like
yeah so boom I'm out so I'm on
deployment I
it's a really interesting deployment
um
I don't know how much I can go into this
one just other than I was running a an
Emergency Task Force at that time and it
was we were wildly successful and uh you
know you met the Admiral that spoke at
my retirement and he became a really
close mentor to me because basically I
did a lot I went so far above because
you know when you're I thought that
since my concept is signed by like The
Joint Chiefs of Staff that means no one
below that can say no to me that's kind
of how I felt about it and uh it turns
out that's actually not true so I was
skipping like layers in the chain of
command I mean I I moved to I moved to
U.S ship truly I also launched some
assets out of different countries
trying to clear the airspace and I just
really went way out over my skis and I
remember I went and woke them up and I'm
like hey uh this is what I did this and
this and he looks at me and he's like
huh
he goes Jimmy I'm not sure what you did
and but we're going to go upstairs and
we're going to make sure this goes well
and then after that we're going to have
a conversation about who's a decision
maker and who's a decision facilitator
and like I learned a lot from him
because he didn't try to crush my spirit
right it's like you said I want to do
good I just I got deployed on one day
notice I don't and my turnover was a
high five turnover which means I get off
the plane and he flies back on the plane
that I got on so I didn't know so anyway
he uh he didn't break my spirit and we
had some really cool things you know
down there he I had my own Jiu Jitsu
Fight Club you know like we do and he
would come to it and we had all the
different people from different agencies
coming to it you know guys have a black
eye and there's kind of like a little
like um you're training with Jimmy and
the boys and it was pretty cool
um they end up having like a little
Civil War in this country for a while
and I had to go out and grab some teams
speaking Arabic was huge I actually
drove right up to a tank in a Toyota
Avalon and I was like hey man do you
mind moving this tank so I can uh and
the guy's looking at me trying to
explain to me that there's a fight going
on and I'm like I totally get you I feel
you but I just need you to move the tank
for long enough for me to and the guy
finally looked at me and shook his head
like okay and I went out and you know
got those things back and it was a
really interesting deployment uh we were
worried about the embassy getting
overrun eerily close to what's going on
in Benghazi to how that went down to be
honest because you know the Ambassador
was like hey you guys are coming over
the wall if things go wrong I'm like oh
yeah
um he didn't know there's three of us
it's his three of us to come over the
wall we had 19 Fast Company Marines
which they would have done a good job
I'm sure like not being facetious at all
you know they get after it so but that
was kind of how it went down over there
um
where were you at when extortion went
down I just got back from deployment and
uh you know extortion I lost my best
friend you know John Tomlinson he worked
for you yeah you remember when he got in
that big fight I do yeah and uh I was
worried because he you were his boss so
John Thomas was my roommate and he
he goes out okay he's not an angel he
was probably like picking up their
girlfriend or something you know he was
a big looking dude and he was walking
out of the bar on the street guys
tackling from behind and he like slides
on his gets up and and one of them was a
bouncer too oh the bouncer plus two
other dudes yeah okay three guys
tackling from behind he's down he gets
up they kicked him out of the bar
and so he's leaving the bar yeah
and this this so then they they came
after him right so I'm just saying all
the ways that he was right right he
didn't know yeah like he was walking
they tackled him from buying so now you
got three dudes tackling you from behind
JT gets up and puts them he puts him in
the hospital like Jaws wired shut and it
turns out that uh these dudes were in
the Navy and so now the Navy wants to
press charges against him and I was
concerned and I'm like and you know JT's
he had a blood infection because like
you get those streaks that go down your
veins when you get infected and I was
like you gotta go to hospital bro I was
like you go to hospital I'll go talk to
Jocko because I I was like I walked into
your office I'm like hey man
um I just want to let you know what
happened with JT and you're like what
you gotten thought with three guys in
one I need tough guys I was like
yeah that's kind of how it went down but
I know they want to Mast him and stuff
and Draco was like yeah I got it and
that was kind of it and I don't know
nothing really happened of it but I'll
tell you exactly what happened yeah
um he went to cat he went to commodore's
Mast yeah and the Commodore
so the Commodore and other Navy dudes
were in there the Navy guys he got a
fight with yeah and their their Master
Chiefs and stuff
and so we're standing there and he busts
him
you busts him he's like yup I do
remember this yeah exactly your
reduction in rank yeah which meant he
wasn't going to be able to screen yeah
and he he had just made Chief yeah so
now he was going to become an E5 yeah I
remember this so the commodore's like
boom boom like you're you're busted like
done
and he's like all right everyone leave
and he's like Jocko stay here
and so everyone leaves and he
he I said Hey sir this guy is um
actually I told him this before I said
hey you remember the guy that you
because he the Commodore just been up in
an exercise yeah and JT was the the uh
jtac calling up at Fallon like calling
all kinds of stuff and yeah Commodore I
go you remember that guy that was up
there and he's like yeah this is the guy
you're about to send to Commodores Mass
right now and he's like okay so anyways
bust him down tells everyone to leave
tells me to stay back
and he gives me the paper
and he goes here you go
and I was like Roger sir
and uh somehow it didn't get filed
somehow that paper did not make no way
uh into his record and yeah and you know
what that Commodore who's no longer with
us he became an admiral
um who he was a guy that was trying to
look out for like a tough good freaking
team guy yeah like what do you want him
to do we got to jump by three guys
that's what do you want him to do
exactly uh and you know it's one of
those things I always think like well if
JT would have gotten busted he wouldn't
have gone to damn neck you know yeah
yeah he wouldn't have been
so it's one of those things but he was
doing what he wanted to do so back to
extortion one seven and you know so my
roommate I get back from deployment I've
got my kids visiting me out in Virginia
Beach and I get a call in the middle of
night hey get to the command
I I get I'm like what's this about I
don't know I drive up there 6 a.m on my
flight going back to tell his family
because you know like if you don't know
uh Echo and people outside the teams
when you go on deployment there's this
like people would consider it morbid
that you fill out about well before you
go it's like who are your pallbearers
what songs do they pay play at your
funeral who do you not want at your
funeral where's your will it's 24 pages
long and you go through this and it's
actually super important because it
solves a lot of problems and I'm the guy
making notification I knew it I know his
family I get there and I drive I fly to
Minneapolis I drive down there bull met
us there uh he just showed up because
he's a good dude and uh we go in there
and I walked up to his dad
uh you know I've got two more people
from the command with me who are gonna
they're just squared away like they're
just squared away people to come with me
as part of the Keiko team what does
Keiko stand for casualty assistance
something I don't know but it's the
person that tells a family that they
lost somebody so I'm in my Blues I show
up and his dad sees me his dad's like
I've been expecting you and George's man
a few words I'm like yes sir and we sat
down we didn't say much and then his mom
came home she was at her 45th she was
retiring at 45 years as a nurse and you
know I'm like you're gonna tell her me
he's like I'll do it so he went out
there and told Kathy and you know it's a
hard time there's no way around it and
then after that we started working on
funeral preparations and stuff I had to
go back because I was a little bit
messed up for my last deployment so I
had to get a surgery
bounce back uh three days later and they
had set up everything they had it's a
town of 700 people we got 1500 person
funeral going down so every logistical
issue you can think of you think covet
was a pain imagine like not having
enough hotels and you know we're
bringing in a C-130 with a bunch of guys
from you know a bunch of Team guys and
uh where do you house this the answer
was the school we had like a one one a
gymnasium and then overflow into like
the theater and stuff anyway I learned a
really important lesson that day and um
you know it's one of the most important
lessons of my life and I always consider
it like uh JT's Parting Gift To Me
and so you know I get back from that
thing and back then we had spreadsheets
that's what we did a piece of paper with
like names and jobs and those two I'll
call them text Tech supports what we
call them normally there's probably a
more PC name for it but it's not
derogatory they're just they're
non-seales who are at the steel command
they did a great job really good job and
uh you know their friends minded this
day and they
on it I'm like okay I'm probably a
pallbearer
I'm probably speaking you know I'm
probably giving his mom a flag
I'm flipping through I'm like nope not
Paul Bearer okay that's weird not
speaking
what am I doing
I am handling the VIPs
don't get pissed I'm like
I'm getting mad and I'm getting ready to
go say something and all of a sudden I
stop and it's and then I feel like this
intense shame over me and I'm like
oh
I just want to be recognized for who I
am in JT's life it's about me it's not
about me
and so JT's final lesson to me was to
get over myself
and you know I don't live up to the
humility I would like to all the time
but I hope you know that
I could manifest that in my life after
that and you know what I happened I shut
my mouth and you know what I did I
handled the VIPs and it makes sense I'm
the senior ranking of my friend group
it makes sense and you know what the
guys that carried the coffin didn't drop
him
the the people the guy that spoke did a
better job than I would have for sure he
did a great job you know and guess what
the mom found the right seat and she got
the flag
so and I'm not remembered as The
who had to like make myself a
center of attention you know but I was
super close to doing it
and so you know that's there's there's
always a silver lining and you know
there's nothing good about losing my
best friend I'm not going to say that
but I will say that you know in his
memory there is something I learned
yeah and
what a freaking stud
um freaking Iowa wrestler I trained Jiu
Jitsu I trained here actually I've
always wanted to do something I got to
put something up like a freaking
Kick-Ass memorial thing
um dude and he was a A ranked top 20
triathlete in the Clydesdale division in
his spare time like when you're in the
SEAL Teams you don't have a lot of spare
time that dude he was just a phenomenal
and we called him the human Labrador
like what better compliment can you get
than that you know what I mean like he
was just everybody's friend yeah he'd do
something we'd scrap it out no guys are
we would be mad and I'd be like I'm
still mad and he'd look at me like like
10 minutes later I was like what you're
still mad about that it was like 10
minutes he's like so how long have you
be mad I'm like okay I'm not mad like it
just it was just that way you know yeah
so
yeah and I mean that that I mean that
obviously that time for nsw was just a
freaking disaster with extortion one
seven which is horrible and I mean
that's one you know that's one
just one guy you know and that uh as
much as that impact was it was that
impact over and over and over again
throughout the community and throughout
all those families man it was just a
freaking nightmare
um
what what did you end up doing after
that what was your next command where'd
you go so I went over I went back to
team five and uh you know my old platoon
Chief I can say his name you know Jason
Tory
um yeah you're smiling go ahead say it
was just the other JT oh dude the other
JT but yeah no Jason's like what he was
my LPL yeah he's my lpo when I was at
Seal Team seven yeah and just freaking
hyper squared away yeah he came over to
me when I was oh I see my chief was a
great guy but he wasn't doing a good job
and I was defending him till the end of
the Earth and then and JT actually got
on JT my chief State he gets on him in
the midfront of everybody and I pull him
aside I'm like hey bro like that's my
chief don't do that to him in front of
the guys and he's like well I'm the
assaults the assaults lead and if I'm
gonna do this I gotta squirm away and
like we kind of got into it and then so
then they end up firing my chief and
then guess who I get JT is my chief and
I'm like oh that guy here we go but I
mean all of a sudden in the house I had
nothing to do I'm like oh yeah like the
assault got ran everything just was
running and I was like dude hyper
squared away dude he's working now
um I think he's chief officer at scilabs
up in up in Washington doing great
things and uh so he's he he calls me
he's like hey if you want to leave there
why don't you come here I need a I need
an officer I'm like oh you think you can
make it happen he's like hell yeah dude
I fly in there and it was just it was
awesome really good deployment really
good work up we would have to have
Afghanistan if he was your sea he was my
sea as well oh yeah and uh you know I
didn't have to I didn't have to talk
much you know JT talks a lot yeah yeah
but he made up for you he made up he'd
say his thing and I I would just sit
back and he always deferred to me like
you anything sir I'd be like most of the
time no and it was kind of cool because
it gave him an extra gravitas when I did
have something to say you know they'd be
like oh he's going to talk this time
because JT's just he's that good you
know you know him yeah yeah dude and
he's freaking just like a character he's
hilarious as a operational seal hell
yeah yeah but also like just to have fun
and hang out yeah crazy with like just
just always having a good time and when
I say I always have a good time I mean I
no matter where you are like we're in
Iraq yeah and like we're having a good
time like things are funny things are
fun things are good which is the coolest
thing about the teams like no matter
where you are
you can have guys we're gonna have fun
no matter what like the shittiest
situation the worst the hottest the
coldest whatever the case is like you
look over at JT and you're gonna he's
got a sound effect for you and a crazy
story and you're like oh okay yeah yeah
so I got him again and you know I picked
up four platoons rolled over to
Afghanistan had a really phenomenal
deployment I mean those guys were so
good I was pretty hard on them during
the workup
um but they did they did a good job I
had really good oic's and then uh you
know of course Bobby came over as one
and uh yeah they did great and on that
deployment I think we had 168 dudes
and uh I'm not going to go into kill
counts and stuff but we had a we did a
lot you know they found like over 24 000
pounds of hme homemade explosives
um they were covered a drone they did
all sorts of cool stuff and just really
cool I would just show up as a guest
assaulter that's what I would do you
know what I mean like you know how to
run your thing you know the battle space
owner like you want to run an element
maybe but if you if you need element
lead like well no we got a guy so I'll
just guess the salt and fall in there
and I've had some really cool Ops with
those guys man we had a really cool off
on Christmas we were just in Afghanistan
walking through Afghanistan and one of
the guys was like we set up a algl which
is like a grenade launcher and it's belt
fed it's got like a from this hill it
has like a two kilometer reach and he
was up there dressing Santa Clauses
it was really cool man yeah it was
really cool so yeah great deployment and
uh we did lose a guy we lost Chris Pike
um he was not a seal but he was an
operator straight up like the guy was
awesome he was built like a gorilla
a tech one of the technical guys yeah
technical guy so They Carried he carried
around this technical equipment that
would help us
um I don't know I'm not going to go too
deep in there she carried around
technical equipment but he was strong
you know he didn't try to pretend he was
a team guy but he could operate it was
competent and uh you know
uh he was a I went to his funeral and
his mom and his family I'm like oh I see
where they come from you know his mom
spoke at his memorial I don't know a lot
of moms that can do that and you know
she had a little maybe a little tear in
her eye but she's she's looking right
out at us and as intense as you can as
tense as you can get and she's like
don't let anybody cry for us we're
warriors we're Pikes and I was like dang
I hope you have a lot more kids cheers
that's what we need so yeah
any other uh major Lessons Learned From
from being a troop Commander yeah man
being a troop Commander you know I I
think I really I kind of that was one of
my better
my better performances in the teams not
to sound overly arrogant but I I was
ready for it you know I fell into it I
was tactically good enough I didn't have
to worry about you know how my weapons
work or anything I could shoot with the
guys as as well as anybody and I could
really sit back I had a great Chief a
great SCA and really solid Chiefs all
those guys are in master chief now it
was just a really phenomenal deployment
guys did their did their piece I did get
in trouble once right when I got there
which I I was like great so I threw a
keg party at Danny's and you know
I I just decided to buy a keg for
everybody get to know everybody and uh I
left not super late but I mean not but I
left before The Keg was done and so one
of my guys stayed and decided to like
you know kill the keg
and uh he went out to have a cigarette I
guess I'm sure he was helping old lady
across the street or something and uh he
gets rolled up by the cops for being
super drunk you know
so he gets put he gets put in the drunk
tank and then and then after he gets put
in the drunk tank
um they release him the next morning and
they tell him there's no paperwork or
anything
so he goes and he tells his chief
and his chief is like wait there's no
paperwork
oh well I'll just keep that so for all
you listeners out there that are not
policemen you I don't think you can put
someone in jail overnight without uh
without paperwork I think you have to
put something down on paper right so
anyway so they don't tell me I don't
find out about it it goes up to the top
through warcom right the highest guys
the Admiral so my bosses bosses boss
tells my boss's boss who tells my boss
who tells who comes out to Nyland I
think to check out how awesome we are
because I'm like yeah I mean we're
awesome he wants to see some awesomeness
this is where you come and so yeah we
were out at you know we're driving to
siphon 16 next you know the one with all
the point of hard rocks yeah I'm going
to siphon 60 I'm like oh you wait tweak
it down there you're going to see some
real awesomeness anyway the the
committee officer and the master chief
like hey why don't you come uh ride with
me Jimmy and JT I'm like yeah okay so we
sit in the back and right when I get in
there he's like so when you guys get to
DUI when are you gonna tell me about
that I'm like
I'm like
um I don't think you're you're right who
was it he gave me the name I'm like no
way
there's no way I know that guy there's
no way he goes well you got a police
report that says that I'm like will you
give me a couple minutes to figure it
out so I'll walk out
he tells me the story it wasn't DUI he's
I told Chief I tell a question well you
know I didn't I didn't think there's any
paperwork I am like you feel the fire
like are you kidding me you know so I
get back to the boss and I'm like
I'm like yeah this is what actually
happened and you know he goes what do
you want me to do about it and I was
like hold me publicly accountable in
front of my guys please
and my boss goes uh
that's not what I expected you to say I
don't know if that's the right thing I'm
like nope you do that and I got the rest
it's like just you need to hammer me in
front of the guys
he said okay so you know we had the Seal
team got together and we got in this
room and he wrote me a letter of Badness
whatever you maybe it's a knit block or
something I don't know how bad it was it
was a letter of Badness and anyway read
it in front of everybody
and then walked out yeah how are you and
uh you know I looked at my guys and I
was like all right guys I didn't even
didn't say a thing no you don't need to
I had nothing to say I was like listen
this was our one our one Silver Bullet
like everyone at this team is going to
go to Afghanistan every one of them want
to go
this it's ours to lose so all these
things that are gonna your focus is that
and if it's not if it's not that it
needs to blur out
all right that's it and you know that
dude was a good dude he was dying to get
punished he was like please hold me he
was he wanted that gift of
accountability and I didn't give it to
him and I know that was a cruel thing to
do really because had I hammered him he
would have felt better but I didn't I
didn't say a thing and that dude ended
up being sailor of the year at Team five
and he's a master chief now and you know
him yeah yeah and so you know I I
learned yeah I'm toward the end of my
tactical career there I kind of knew how
to navigate their circles and I was like
these guys don't want to see me get
strung up you know so they really
cleaned up their act and they had a
great deployment and I
it was
phenomenal nine months in Afghanistan
other than losing Chris Pike you also
told me about
um learning some resilience from one of
your guys I think he's still active but
yeah he is still active and I'm not
going to say his name I'm just going to
call him Don so this dude that that same
group that was out in Afghanistan I had
a group out in the West in Hellman
working for the Marines and because the
battle space owner the Marines own that
battle space if you don't know and
within that are different groups but we
all answer to the battle space owner
because he has to coordinate everything
that happens in there so
um he you know Point man solid dude he
can brief he's a level three which is
like human intelligence stuff he's just
a sharp dude who do you put on point you
put the dudes who are sharp and this guy
is a Mexican dude and he's up front and
he sees an Afghani about to step on an
IED he runs up to grab him too late boom
blows that Afghani in half kind of
smashes Donny up a little bit and he it
he lost his eyes eyes are gone he's got
to trach in uh pretty blown up lost some
of his hand because like the frag came
up blew his hand up gets blown up and I
remember thinking
all right like I don't know how bad it
is but I wasn't on the Opps they flew
him into Ballroom I go see him in
ballroom and I'm we're putting them on
the plane and the lady's like hey he's
uh he's not responsive
I was okay so I kind of take him by his
hand and he's got a trick and he can't
talk he can't see and I kind of like hey
buddy it's Jimmy how you doing man
he struggles to sit up and I'm like
What's Happening he wants to communicate
so we try and get him a whiteboard but
he can't see he's got to write with his
off hand because his good hands blown up
and he's we figure out he's trying to
tell me he wants to come back and I'm
like
this guy
so I
I tell him I was like listen buddy like
you know it's important for the guys to
see you do
recover they're worried about you so
what I would like you to do would you
please send videos of your recovery to
the guys
stay in touch with us and if you get
better
I'll bring you back
and that guy
did it Don got blown up on
December the 10th
and so I go out there I spend the
holidays with him and
we're getting ready to go on op and you
see you see him he sends a video of him
running on the treadmill he's sweating
and the guys are cheering and you know
the the physical therapy staff are
distraught at what's happening you know
with this guy putting out and it was
cool man the guy it was they kept him in
touch and you know he didn't make it
back on deployment his injuries were too
great
um but that he still had Community he
still had a purpose and he still had a
goal and you know we sent a guy home
from our deployment after he got shot in
the plate and we didn't do anything for
him we sent him home and gave him time
and I don't think he had the same kind
of recovery you know
whereas
what Don ended up doing was you know he
came back and he wanted to get back in
the teams somehow and I grew back I'm
not a doctor I don't know he's a badass
you know he just I grew back an eye he's
like I won't come back in the teams and
so a lot of the higher ups were like no
you can't bring him back to teams he has
to have peripheral vision CQC skydiving
and I'm pissed I'm like just give them
to me I'll take him you know and I'm the
opso now at at five and they're against
it and they're like well what if he does
sqt I'm like okay well just maybe just a
couple blocks that's a slap in the face
man like you know what I mean this is a
seasoned operator like anyway so I'm
like that's fine
um which blocks we have to do and it was
like Close Quarters combat and skydiving
and because they're like making Jewel
off I'm like he doesn't have to breathe
underwater again like that's that's
ridiculous anyway
he I went and told him I'm like hey bro
listen this is they said they can bring
you back but this is what you got to do
he's like oh cool I'll do the whole
thing I'm like no no no no he's like no
no I'll do the whole thing
he did he's the only uh enlisted guy to
ever speak at an sqt graduation and he
was the honor man for Miss sqt how are
you awesome and he's still he's still
out there right now he's going to do a
beyond the Brotherhood with me after
this and uh super proud of that dude and
uh you know I learned that from I
learned about those important things
about resilience along the way and I
think maintaining that Community he's
still part of the team you know
maintaining the uh the purpose and the
goals was super important and that's one
of the things I'm trying to do with the
beyond the Brotherhood which I'm sure
we'll get to in a little bit
freaking outstanding uh what'd you do
after that yeah after that you went to
buds right as uh XO Kicking and
Screaming because I'm like they're like
hey man I screened EXO third look which
is your last possible look because I
never took a real staff tour I just
didn't do that I just kept going they're
like you've only gone to the Middle East
you only you know just done sealed teams
you need to do some other things they
want you to do boats or sdv anyway so I
somehow made XO so now you have to go do
an EXO tour so that's my first ever
staff tour I didn't know about all the
Navy programs just like 24 Navy programs
like motorcycle safety and like all I
didn't I hadn't taken a PRT in like
seven years I didn't know and they're
like well you're fit rep so you take it
I'm like I don't know like I didn't know
I didn't know we still took the PRT I
just didn't even know so now on the XO
in charge of all this admin stuff I
don't even know about and uh had a great
staff there I still stay in touch with
uh with some of those ladies they were
uh one of them she just put on Warren
officer I'm super proud of her and uh no
it's it was it was a really good tour
for me I didn't realize how far gone I'd
been because like when you're if you
walk into a coal mine you're going to
get a little dirt on you you know it
makes me think of that one you you did a
podcast where there was a guy living in
like the CIA World or one of those
worlds with Intel it's a dirty World
well going to combat over and over for
14 years
is going to leave a stain and I didn't
realize where I was and then you know
being at Shore and being home and oh
it's still you know I'm a normal person
and it took a while for that stuff to
kind of bleed off but it was really good
for me and uh being a buds you know we
learned a lot when I learned a ton while
I was there and back to the resilience
thing we had um we had a suicide there
so this was a guy that quit right yeah I
was you got to quit I think the proper
word used to be a trite I don't know
what it is now they always have a
phoenix division or something I'm trying
to be good by nsw but we called him a
tried spec then so usually when guys
quit they you take them you give them
the man talk with the master chief which
is like usually some big stud you know
the dude who was at the time uh and uh
he was like get and then you're going to
put him in bed because they've been
awake for two or three or four days well
this guy didn't do that jumps in a car
drives downtown jumps off the 24th floor
of the Marriott
and you know we're like and then we
start looking at the stuff we're like
wait there was some kind of suspect car
accidents where some guys lost could
there be I don't know we don't know but
we had we know that we've got at least
one suicide and we have to do something
about it and so I had a couple of these
lieutenants and by this time you know
nowadays these CL officers are so
freaking smart they're all ivy league
guys they're all 1600 sat guys and these
two guys went to MIT and I was like hey
I need you guys to design something
let's figure out
well what we can do with these better to
treat these guys and they came up with
the ahrock the hell week recovery
Observation Center and they were like
look after you quit you got to spend 24
hours in the ahrock and during that time
well first before you start hell week
you have to put down the name of one
person that you're going to call when
you finish hell week that that that name
that's first then you have to talk to
this like you have to spend 24 hours in
there and you have to I have to get a
med check and then you can go you can
leave so
I I looked at this I'm like that's the
worst idea ever this is going to be like
Jonestown the day after it's gonna be
one mass suicide they're always going to
like be in this huge pity party and
they're going to allow you know but
that's not what happened they it made
this sense a community they're in there
watching eating pizza watching movies
and then you realize hey I'm not the
minority no one talks about quitting
buds no one does and now you've got all
these guys who are in the same boat you
know every one of them is the biggest
badasser their towns their families ever
known you know and oh and then they have
to call that name and that's an
interesting wrinkle too because now it's
like okay my family they love me because
I'm the best I'm The Golden Child
you know those calls how do you think
those go you think it's like you're dead
to me no when they call it's like hey
I'm proud of you you know do great
things in Navy and so it breaks that
glass
and it gives them a community
and then we start working on their next
jobs and they get goals and purpose and
it really was a really cool thing that
we uh
that we did and it worked out great to
my knowledge there's been zero suicides
from guys from a traits after Buds and
uh
yeah I think I it was something that I
learned a lot about resilience that I
didn't know from these young lieutenants
who are smarter than ours when you got a
guy like you and me kind of you you said
when you were going through Bloods you
didn't think about quitting I didn't
definitely didn't think about quitting
when I was going through buttons at all
what did you learn from these guys like
hearing them talk the out brief when
somebody just so did you do that out
brief as well are you sitting there for
some of those well no it's not really an
outbreak you're talking about the man
talk see out brief yeah we talked to him
on the back side and usually we is
usually not me
um you know we have the the psych and
stuff we'll talk to him
um what kind of stuff do they say
well a lot of times they
I I after so before and after hrock
because when after aatroc it was a lot
different
um but before a lot of these guys were
just like I got to get back I lost I
lost the focus I lost Focus or no I
don't remember quitting I was
hallucinating or there I always a lot of
times they had some kind of excuse after
the aatroc I didn't see that as much you
know and what an interesting thing was
uh one time the mick pond that's the
master chief petty officer of the Navy
that's the like I'm saying it for your
people not for you is the highest
ranking list of guy there is in the
whole world like he's the top dude he's
the only guy with a third star on his
little anchor and uh he came up to me
and he's like hey man you know I was a
budget right I'm like no like bro you
gotta tell people that that'd be a great
thing for these guys to know that they
could
they could you know quit not make it and
now they could become the mcpon and uh
he's like no I don't want to talk about
it I was like dang that would have been
a great thing for him to do you know
so when you're seeing these guys like if
if someone's listening to this right now
and they're like thinking about going to
buds yeah and one thing I've always said
is like if the three of us were going to
Buds and you were wanting to make it
because your ex-girlfriend said you
could never make it and you're gonna
move around no I think you can make it
and and Echo wants to make it because
you know he wants to prove to his dad
and I want to make it because I'm
patriotic all three of those guys could
make it
we could also all three not make it like
whatever that Y is I don't think it
really matters like I know guys that
were like oh just no one thought I could
do it so I was doing it that was me yeah
so there you go that's like a classic
situation I didn't have anything yeah it
and there's guys that are like you know
I I'm doing this because I believe in
service and they quit like freaking day
too so they have these big like uh super
philosophical reasons and they don't
make it they quit now look again some
people that have big super philosophical
reasons they don't quit some people that
they're doing it for their because
they're they want to prove their
ex-girlfriend wrong sometimes they quit
sometimes they don't is it what I'm
saying is like
you just gotta you just gotta want to
freaking do it as far as I'm concerned
yeah I I don't know we tried we did a
lot of things trying to find the magic
sauce and really one of the best things
we figured out was that we they made
this thing where they put all the rack
and stack these scores and some of the
major components are self assessment
Cadre assessment peer assessment and
they look at those things and if those
things align pretty close the guys do
better that and oddly enough being close
with your mother hmm was another Common
Thread I don't know what that says but
those were some of the few things we
could do when you say the self pure and
Cadre assessment so if we all think if
like okay the Cadre thinks I'm
like not the best athlete but I'm a
tough guy and I think I'm not the best
athlete and I'm a tough guy and my peers
think I'm the best at I'm not the best
athlete but I'm a tough guy those lenses
align and you're probably
you have a better chance because you're
you know what's going on but if you're
like I'm the best athlete ever and
they're like man he's a little slow and
you know just being that maybe it's a
maturity thing with your frontal lobe I
don't know but if if those things align
pretty closely it's been and that and of
course there's a baseline physical
fitness people are like it's all mental
well it's more mental if you're not in
good shape you know like yeah I've
always told people hey man you know that
rope climb it doesn't matter how mad you
want to climb up that road climb you can
really really really really really want
it yeah but when you can't do it you
can't do it and all the want and all the
mental strength in the world you gotta
freaking train for that you got to be
physically ready for it and for all
those buds uh gundabies out there you
know just the Baseline you know mile and
a half running boots and pants nine
minutes uh your five premiere swim nine
minutes 20 pull-ups if you can't do that
don't show up
um and then uh what's the other one 100
100 100 push-ups 100 sit-ups that's
right you do those things and you've got
the physical tools to make it if you
don't
it's going to be harder it's going to be
harder yeah yeah yeah I think did you
say now you're good at pull-ups you're
not a hard pull-up guy what you're
running was your thing wasn't it I I was
not great at anything and not horrible
at anything so that's a good place to be
yeah I I never want to run
I failed one I never want to swim I
failed one which there's a lot of swims
you can fail there's a lot of runs you
can fail I never won the O course I
never failed one like so I was just like
uh in the middle of the pack yeah not a
bad place to be yeah I think I got
gooned like one time
um in the Goon Squad that's a slippery
slope yeah yeah yeah it can't be but
like that that's why you know if you
only get goon one time yeah you learn
your lesson I was like yo whatever it
takes to stay up with the pack is worth
it yeah so so Echo if you get gooned
once like let's just say we're running
and they decide that this is the cut off
for people who are running fast enough
so everyone behind them has to get in
this so if you made it past that you're
running in a circle nice and slow and
catching your breath if you didn't
you're hitting the surf and doing
push-ups and just getting beat down and
now we take off again and guess what you
know you're probably not going to do
real well so that slippery slope just
gets worse and worse so it's like you
best decide to just put out because once
you get gooned once it's yeah did you
work hella weeks while you're there I
did not
um I
you know there's a lot of things I had
to do and I don't really I've never sent
a single person to Surf I've never I
don't yell at people it's just not my
thing it's not my style so I went out I
brought him Pizza on some nights I
always like to go to the uh Camp surf
where they like dig that big microphone
and they tell jokes you know and uh it's
it's a really cool like indoctrination
of teams it's like day four you're
probably gonna make it and I remember
they're like okay someone tell a joke
and they like had couches out there and
I had I'd bring burritos and pizza for
the Cadre and we're watching them and
you know
uh the my buddy Beau was the uh he's in
her charger for his face he always ran
that and he's like okay tell a joke and
someone would get up and they'd start to
tell a joke that Mike maybe it was
racist or something he'd be like hit the
surf everybody before you finish it so
please hit the surf you know they come
back and maybe they would tell a joke
that was like sex or something I hit the
surf everybody in the middle of it and
like after a while you see someone get
up and start to tell joking class would
be like shut up but
but tone stutter for like hey we don't
do that here you know what I mean it was
really cool uh you know because they're
boys and they're all like they want to
say things but you know he really he set
that until he used that as like a hey
that's not how we do these things here
so yeah pretty cool I mean you would
also you have another kid at this point
right yeah I do I got a little Savage
yeah yeah you know him the Little Beast
I ain't gonna bust his name out but if
you know if he sees if he sees Jocko
he's gonna grab him by the neck and try
and put him out I know he always
approaches me as if what is it like it's
like he shakes my hand and he looks me
in the eyes and he how old is he right
now nine so he's been doing that since
he was like six yeah like coming up to
me shaking my hand and looking me in the
eyes like
good to see you
he's got like the soul of a freaking 32
year old veteran dude that cost me five
gummy bears to teach him because like I
used to bring in the mornings I trained
with uh you know the wolf pack you know
Morgan and Bram and Junior you know
those guys I've trained with every
morning and I bring him in there like
and he would he would train with me for
five minutes just because I want him to
be the gym is a fun place right and then
I'd put him in thing with a little TV in
his breakfast and then I'd go fight with
the boys and uh my friends would come in
he wouldn't he wouldn't walk up and and
shake down he's hiding behind my leg I'm
like what are you doing bro he's like
I'm new I'm I'm kind of so I read this
book about how like loss aversion is
more powerful than like if I tell you
I'm Gonna Give You 500 that's not as
powerful as I give you 500 and I take it
back right so I'm like okay let me try
this new psychology power I have on my
five-year-old and I I give him I'm like
hey hey buddy here's five gummy bears
put them in your pocket they're yours
but you can't eat them until after class
so every time someone comes up and you
don't shake their hand
I'm gonna throw one gummy bear away
okay can you do that he's like yes sir
I'm like okay we say yes sir yes I'm at
my house and I'm like okay so we go up
there and sure enough Morgan comes up
the stairs and he's hiding behind my leg
and I'm like oh oh hey give me those
Gummy Bears please and he like takes it
out and gives it to me you know that
metal trash can we have right next to
that it's right next to the water
fountain clay it's a clang it's like 20
feet from here I laugh when I see it and
his face look horrified like just I
can't believe he just threw away the
sugary goodness and then he you know
he's like okay I'm like are you gonna do
it now or do I need to take another one
he's he walks up he shakes his hands and
then people react they're freaked out
they're like what is this kid all
intense and so good now now it's his
game yeah man so a few parents out there
five gummy bears is all it takes yeah
yeah I never recognize that loss
aversion thing I know all the the the
punishment that I had with my son was
I took one of his toys and brought it to
the concrete patio and smashed it with a
hammer uh because he's done something a
little more intense he had done he had
done something that was unacceptable
in my family
and so yeah and so people like I can't
believe you did that you know how many
times I did it once once and then I had
a staging area and I took his next
favorite toy and I put it in the staging
area and I was like this one's next if
anything like this if you if you're out
of line wow and he couldn't really speak
very well because he was only four
but he was like he was like six though
he would change your own diaper and he
was like he was like check so I only had
to only do it one time and it left a
mark right yeah you don't want to lose
the the favorite toys yeah so there you
go so you got him now and then after
that you go back to
uh you didn't you go to the deploy again
yeah it looked like 2017. the second
half of the mosul fight with uh we did
western mosul which was like that big
fight with Isis
um and it was an interesting thing now
it has two thing called a2e a3e like
advise a company and assist and everyone
wanted to go with the company is the
third a and that's what everyone wants
because the guys now you got these new
guys who want to come in and they're
like they're trying to prove themselves
because they got all these combat vets
but the war ain't the same anymore right
and so these it's time for the Iraqis to
defend their own country and you know
these guys want to go in and get in the
mix but really you know we can like Mark
the Iraqis where they are let the Iraqis
fight when they get stuck they are not
uh technically Savvy enough to like do
the combined arms things with the
aircraft and calling the jtac because
you know calling in bombs is it's not
super hard but there's pretty big
consequences right on a risk assessment
it's like
it would be catastrophic yeah
catastrophic so
we do that for them
you don't have to be there on the ground
with them to do that and the guys really
like struggle with that because they're
like come on so we we made this rule you
had to be one kilometer off the flot the
forward line of Trace so the Iraqis are
pushing you've got to be 1K back and
then you can call on the strikes and
that's on the that's on the with the
company usually you can do it from The
Jock you don't even need to go and you
know the guys really struggle with that
but you know I don't want to send a guy
home in a box for for that country
anymore you know and we we went into
that and it was actually super super
good but it was interesting seeing how
much the guys were always trying to find
a way to get up there they're always
trying to find a way to get in the fight
and I'm like well how close are you well
it's going to be closer but I can
support with a 50 cal and I'm like bro I
know man I know I know I know but what's
happening here is going to happen
whether you're up there and getting shot
at or not you know so yeah it was an
interesting place for me to be on the
other side right I'm sure there's
someone like oh Jimmy's weak he's you
know you were you were the guy pulling
the reins oh I was the I was the deputy
commander of the Cedar sotoff and then I
was the commander for a while so that's
like all special forces in Iraq and
Syria because the boss had to go home
because he had a family issue in uh you
know nsw was like we'll send a guy over
and he's like no no let's have Jimmy do
it and you know now I'm running these
commanders who are way senior than I am
yeah that's wild yeah it was and they
know me it's the teams you know and uh I
because in my mind I'm like there's no
one here that can tell me I can't go on
up I'm going you know what I mean you're
immediately yeah you immediately went to
the same oh yeah I was like so I think
I'm gonna go on an OP so I go on this op
and the guys were like oh here sir this
is where you're sitting I'm like okay do
you want me to
gun Drive where am I like you just sit
right here I'm like oh you're that I'm
this I'm the combat vet like what a
spectator now like oh I'm like no guys I
can really help but no you know what
it's not a place for me to be the guys
did a great job I went on and off with
them and I'm like okay
I am that guy who is uh you know it's
past my Prime
yeah exactly so I didn't go on anymore I
just went on that one and they were good
it was some team seven guys but yeah so
we did the mosul fight it was it went I
think that really the integration with
technology unprecedented level
guys didn't get to get the scrap on they
wanted to get but also we didn't hurt a
lot of guys we lost C4 Charlie Keating
yeah you know but
yeah the technology advancement was so
incredible like our deployment when you
and I were together 2006
like the the the uavs and stuff oh yeah
or just like
pathetic yeah and I remember our uh one
of my officers it was actually leif's
one of the life's assistant platoon
commanders he was he was like the UAV
guy and like every time he would launch
for those things it was a recovery
I remember we gave him such a hard time
they were hitting walls hitting
buildings in the trees and and I was at
the first aquapuma is that what it was I
don't know what it was but and not only
that but the imagery sucked you know it
was like from a shaky little freaking
camera that was on target like one
quarter of the time so they and and it
just turned into the Technologies got so
good so fast and by the time you guys
were over there was like incredible yeah
incredible and also the enemy had it as
well yeah you see some of the stuff
that's going on right now in Ukraine
where there's like drones dropping hand
grenades have you seen some of those
videos yeah we were worried about that
in in mosul too and actually they had
all sorts we like tried all sorts of
different things and somebody came up
with like the idea of having these
Falcons swooping down and taking out the
drones I'm like
that'd be cool I mean it'd be cool to
see like like what's more America than
an eagle swapping outside and grabbing a
drone a bad guy drone but uh we ended up
finding lots of different things but
really the best thing to do is just
because the Drone had had a return
address it had to go back right and so
once that thing goes back you follow it
in with Hellfire and that was kind of
the most successful thing in my opinion
that's that's a pretty good success yeah
how you like me now yeah yeah you drop
your little 40 mic cell and then you eat
a Hellfire hey when did you when did you
end up you did like the executive uh
what do they call it when you went to
Harvard because you didn't go there
right no it's program leadership
development it's because I was looking
around for an Executive MBA and uh you
know I went all the I was like I'll do
stsu or I'll do and someone's like but
every place was accepting me USC I'm
like wow maybe I should start at the top
and work my way down see what happened
so I threw out like Harvard Stanford and
then got accepted and I was like oh well
I guess I should go now so I went to
that and it was actually awesome it's
basically their MBA curriculum you do
all the case studies and then you do six
weeks on campus it's nine month long and
then you do one more module and it ends
up you as a alumni and uh it was great
with the best thing I got out of there
is a network I mean I tell people now I
think school is overrated like if you're
going to be a engineer or a doctor
you've got to go school man but if
you're going to run business my
brother's awesome in business he doesn't
didn't even go to he finished high
school barely you know and uh it's
there's just I think that entrepreneur
line is we need to preserve that and
celebrate that and I don't necessarily
think that college is the right fit for
everybody you know oh yeah I definitely
agree with you a matter of fact I was
just getting an interview the other day
and I was they're like oh less men are
going to college and I was like no I
kind of support that you know good I
mean yeah if you're like you said if
you're gonna be an engineer you're gonna
be a doctor but if you're gonna go
and do like why not go learn how to weld
or go learn how to be an electrician in
a in an 18-month trade school where you
come out with a legit skill that people
actually need in the world so yeah
because all these other things you just
plug into into the big machine making 80
to 100 000 a year and on top of that
college is an it's an indoctrination
it's like non-stop indoctrination and
you know um this is I'm speaking from I
got a daughter who's in medical school
and then my son is just starting at
Tarleton State and uh you know I just
see it it's so much of an indoctrination
they've put all these little things in
it's like well why don't we just teach
them the skills that they need and leave
them alone and I think the trades are
still that way yeah yeah and what would
you but you started a business kind of
around this time frame right yeah I
started Sushi assassin Sushi Echo
Charles now he's entered the chat are
you are you a sushi guy yes
can you say Sushi assassin Sushi
assassin it's kind of hard to say yeah
yeah but uh so I came back from business
school I'm like I got this new business
muscle I got to use and then the teams
you know that's what we do like oh I
learned how to be a horse Master you go
to either so I I went down and I I
speared I'm a big I'd like to Spearfish
I had a like 200 pounds a Yellow Tail
like what I do with this and my buddy's
like bro we should start a sushi thing
I'm like uh do you know a sushi chef
he's like I'm a sushi chef I'm like uh
okay you sure made me some sushi so
trying to like what you did with me and
he did a good job and he's got a really
he's from Kauai actually he he said I
think he said he'd know you his name is
Aaron Bishop um but he grew up he grew
up in Kauai he's like a small framed
little white guy smaller than I yeah
freckles yeah does he have a brother
named Damien yes he does
Aaron Bishop yeah he's older than Damian
yeah anyways my class okay so yeah so
he's a good dude man and uh and he
started this up and you know at the time
I'm super proud of him because he didn't
have a lot going on he was working he
hadn't been his taxes in a couple years
and he just his life was kind of not
going super good and we started Sushi
assassin and he he runs it you know he
runs it he does it I set the business up
and he's got a really nice like vibe to
him phenomenal Sushi if you're in the
San Diego area and you want to do some
sushi get some suit in your house and
what really helped us out was covid
because all of a sudden they shut down
all these mom-and-pop restaurants you
know and no one knows how to make sushi
I mean I kind of can now but I can't
make what he makes you know and so now
you can have the we'll take a PCR test
show up in your house boom minimum of
eight it's about 140 ahead but it's
super good all you can eat you know and
you're in your house if you want to just
you want to drink you drink your own
stuff and then we clean up and leave and
it's been pretty good so he's making a
good living now I don't take money from
it but I want to hand the business off
to him but that was my first foray what
is it Sushi assassin.com no he has an
insta and I think it's Sushi assassin.co
I think that's I don't have I'm new to
social media man I I have a LinkedIn
that's all I have yeah you know it's
like and it's mainly the San Diego area
yeah it's mainly San Diego area check
yeah all right so you're doing that
um
and now we roll into your kind of like
your last your last tours was group one
right yeah I rolled over to there and I
was the opso for a while and then uh
they shut down the Ford units and they
combined everything group one and I was
I was redlining I'm like I was running
all of what used to be down there and
I'm like hey man and the staff hadn't
come here yet so the guys that were
there had to come back and I was like
hey I can't can't maintain this because
I was working from like you know I get
you know what it's like I work at 4 30
and until six get a workout in then go
to work because I we have like zipper
piped into our house I actually had it
hardwired into my house and uh yeah you
just like my friend knew how to do it we
set it up so anyway they I was working
like crazy and I told the boss I'm like
bro I gotta tap out man like we gotta
get we gotta so they split my position
into three we had like the opso the
training officer which is what the group
one Ops used to be and then we had like
the 35 which is like uh combining Intel
and kind of forward-looking Ops anyway
so I'm like I want to take training and
because I'm getting out so that's that's
a king maker job put someone in that
King maker job
so I went to training and uh it was
awesome had a great job I loved it uh
you know I'll just say CB work with me
and one of the best most capable humble
people I've ever met you know I I just
he was your one of your OIC he's my OIC
he's he's the uh Delta Charlie in the
book leadership strategy and tactics
he's the guy that I stole everything
from yeah and you know what and you ask
him what he does he's like I do the
work that's what he says of course
just a phenomenal dude he set up my
whole retirement for me and uh just he
loves a couple Walks from us you know
that he's like yeah yeah but phenomenal
dude and uh work with him and we we ran
that that training and that that went
well and then I kind of like started
working my way out and uh you know I
started a couple other businesses so
until tell us about the what do you got
going on now so now I've got so you well
you retired in 2022 right yeah yeah well
actually technically January 1st but my
retirement that you wouldn't yeah I
spoke at was what December 16th I think
check okay yeah uh but I started Mayday
executive services and we do high-end
events for uh for executives safe
unconventional I just did one just last
three days I've been doing it and I took
some folks riding like water boards
those little water jet boards and we did
some uh we did some water jet board
you'd like stand on it and the jet ski
follows you around and you like ride on
it it almost feels like a hoverboard
okay yeah yeah right yeah we did that
and then we did uh we went strong with
the sharks out in La Jolla which if
you're not from here it's a pretty big
deal and uh and then they don't know but
I actually did see a small great white
when I was out there how big uh seven
foot maybe yeah so la jolla's breeding
ground for Great Whites yeah
um so it's not a surprise to see one
yeah but most of the sharks that you see
in La Jolla are those little leopards
these little leopard sharks that are
they're nice yeah they're nice sharks
they got little bitty mouths they just
like yeah clams or something yeah but
anyway they were pretty it was a big
deal for them and then we also did some
underwater not tying and then I did a
talk with them on yeah
on adjusting your team to change so it
was really good I work with uh this was
through pray.com I work with those guys
all the time uh their CEO Steve Katina
has been a mentor for me on the way out
you met him at my uh at my retirement
and he's I did some work with him early
on like in 2015 I did something for him
I said if I scavenge around or something
and he's like hey can we pay you I'm
like no you can't pay me I just he's
like what can I go like well will you be
my mentor dude that was the best
investment of my life those guys I mean
he's probably texted me 10 times already
today I called him on my way here to
make sure I was squared away and he's
just been phenomenal you know mentor and
leader and just good people you know so
you need mentors inside and out in the
in the military it was you Dave Cooper
um bonakable you know those were my
mentors and then now on the outside I've
got Steve Katina you know he's been
amazing you know so that that is called
uh May Day executive it's at Mayday
executive.com it's
maydayexecutiveservices.com and I've
actually never seen the website my
sister made it I don't pay attention to
it yeah I looked at it yeah I heard it's
messed up on the cell phone right now so
she's got to fix that but on the desktop
it's tight I don't know I don't do a lot
of that I'm mostly Word of Mouth I'm
booked through March right now and uh
I try to just do two two events a month
and sometimes it's speaking I do a lot
of what the entrepreneurs organization
and the young the YPO young business
organization
um and then but my preponderance of my
time is spent on beyond the Brotherhood
right so so talk us through that beyond
the Brotherhood this is a a 501c3 yeah
correct correct and you know people
don't realize how often uh seals kill
themselves it's it's pretty bad like
within four months of my retirement four
of our brothers died by their own hand
and uh it's it's a problem and we're
just I think we're just getting on the
tip of the iceberg because now the guys
that did a lot of the a lot of the
combat are just starting to get out and
I think that you know we talked about
resilience community
purpose goals these guys they're used to
fighting for a higher cause you know
they're fighting maybe it's for
patriotism maybe it's for the guy next
to you it doesn't matter you're part of
a community and now you get out and
you're working for money and a lot of
these guys do fine but years down the
road they lose that Community purpose
sense of goals and so I thought about
what I could do to get after that
problem and you know beyond the
Brotherhood in cooperation with Punta
Brava Surf and golf club I've been doing
work with them for a while and they're
like hey would you start a 501c3 we'll
we'll cover it what do you want to do
I'm like let's get after this problem
and so you know we're just getting
started I did 14 dudes in 2022 and this
year I think we've got 18 so far
um but I don't advertise we take the
guys in and basically I like to use the
Navy programs be an expert at that we
help them get through the VA process
then when they get through that we uh we
plug them into a network because you
know in the teams you're like in a black
hole you you don't really have social
media or anything I got my first social
media account in January and so you we
kind of we we take them we give them the
last bits of what they need so like if
your company trying to hire oh I need
them to have this real estate thing I'll
get them that real estate certificate
I'll send them to you and we we line it
up based on five things that I actually
learned from a different non-profit but
it's like what matters to you most to
put it in order where you want to live
who you work with the mission that
you're doing how much you get paid or
ability to control your own time once I
get that I get a picture of what kind of
thing you need to do and then you know
there's no one-size-fits-none solution
we work with the guys get them placed
and uh where I'm starting I got good
partners I need more so you know of
course we need donors because it's a
501c3 but we also need mentors people
don't want to take these guys and hire
them and I'm finding that they've
they've done really well so if there's a
value proposition on both sides and
we've got a website
beyondthebrotherhood.org and uh you know
it's a way to give back to seal
Community it's important to me Mayday
executive pays the bills
beyond the Brotherhood it's like good
for me and I'm still plugged into the
community and uh you know I think down
the road I think the Magic's not what we
do right now but I think it's gonna be
in five six years these guys are higher
up and they're you know they're at the
the echelona society that they deserve
to be a society that they fought for and
earned
and then now they're looking at what
their life is and maybe they can find
some purpose to give them back to beyond
the Brotherhood maybe they come to our
events or you know they see that
snot-nosed little punk that just like he
was getting out you know what I mean
let's let's get this little fella turned
in the right right direction yeah for
people hiring uh so so if I'm at a
company and I'm looking for somebody to
do a certain job I can go to
beyondthebrotherhood.org yep and I can
say hey I'm looking to hire somebody to
run one of my plants or one of my sites
and you this is what I really liked
about what you're doing talk talk me
through how you are screening guys oh
yeah to no you're preparing on what you
talk about hey when you need a real
estate thing cool we'll get you that
real estate thing but you're also doing
a cool uh methodology for screening them
yeah thank you for bringing that up so
like there's a lot of organizations just
taking anybody you know what I mean but
you don't know who that person is is he
a guy that got you know canned
after a platoon and a half and stole
something and lost his bird he's got a
buzz class next to his name so you know
we screen our guys for character
um if not everybody makes it and when I
say character I I take I have them turn
in when they apply one supervisor one
peer three subordinates and we talk
about those lenses they need to align so
like if they all think that you're a
jerk but you're squared away but you're
even your supervisor say that you're
like all right this this might be the
right guy because everyone sees in the
same but if the kids guys below you
think you're a jerk and above you like
oh he's the nicest person yeah okay
that's that that's not you're not true
across the board and you probably are
not the guy we're looking for so we
screen these guys and you know in the
team's a little about 2500 of us like
you know if I if someone didn't didn't
know me and they asked two or three team
guys they can get a kind of converging
validity of what my reputation is right
so that's what we do we get figure out
who these guys are they're not perfect
but they're pretty good High Caliber
dudes and uh you know we'll give them
what last pitch what they need and send
them on their way and then what's the
deal with the uh with the Punta what is
that Punta Brava yeah what's that all
about Punta Brava so it's a private Surf
and golf club I've been doing work with
them for a while you know I would take
investors out and take them big wave
surfing or take them to the wineries in
Mexico or whatever it is they want me to
do and it's been fun we've got a really
it's a really cool place it's Punta
brava.com
um
but it's going to be one of the best
highest end golf clubs in the world
there's five holes they're designed by
Tiger Woods you have to hit over the
over the water to get on the green and
they're only going to take 360 members
it's super high-end but it is cool it's
so if you know where La Bufadora is just
south of Ensenada I was checking out on
a map it's a peninsula that sticks up
south of Ensenada yeah it's like seven
miles yes seven seven miles out into the
Pacific Ocean so it feels like an island
because there's this huge mountain on it
and man they're breaking ground I think
before the end of this year they're
going to have the they're going to have
a nine hole set up and they're talking
they'll have an airstrip there and uh
just how are the waves the waves not
that good but uh Toro Santos the
world-class big wave spot is a four
minute jet ski ride from there so once
we get the marina set up it's going to
be really easy to bounce out there I
took some dudes out there surfing in 25
foot and uh they they didn't do super
great but they didn't die
my leash end up snapping I had to swim
all the way in and go get it but uh it's
cool I took some guys you're fishing
there a few weeks ago it's a really cool
place man like I mean it's expensive but
if you can afford it it's definitely so
are people going to build houses down
there on that place yeah they got 25
lots that they're selling and uh you
know did they go through the website
they can figure out all the Deets on
that but yeah you can have a house on it
and I think the real estate around there
is going to really bump up and in
addition to beyond the Brotherhood they
sponsor Punta private medical so they're
trying to bring Medical Care to all the
people in that area try and get back to
the community there and you know I got a
soft spot for Mexico I grew up right in
El Paso and i i surf down there all the
time I've been dying to take you down
there
um but yeah it's good people good
Community I really like what's going on
down there
check now if I'm a guy that's getting
out the same thing I go to
beyondthebrotherhood.org yeah you'll
click a little application thing and
then it'll go to our admin which is me
and Sean Murphy
and then one of us will look at it we'll
divide and conquer he takes most of the
East Coast guys I take most of the West
Coast guys and uh and then we we do our
little research if it checks out because
sometimes I got to put you on a wait
because you know I got like a couple
guys in the queue there's only a couple
of us doing it and so I you know I've
got a lot of jobs but I really think
that once be on the road gets up and
running in a couple years especially
when Puna Brava gets the constituency
that they're going to get and uh will be
a centerpiece there and I think it'll be
easier for us but right now I'm super
bad at fundraising I'm not good at
asking people for money I'm just not
good at it like it feels weird you know
but that's kind of what you got to do
for a 501c3
and what else you got you've married yep
yeah so you got that going on yep and
she's awesome she's active duty right
now oh okay so right on going to dim her
out but she's a lawyer all business you
see her on the mat here sometimes she's
out here training yeah yeah and and then
you know when we were talking uh before
you were kind of talking about just like
Broad
like life lessons and one of the things
you were talking about is just like
decision making and at some point
shifting from like making selfish
decisions which might not have turned
out the best in the long run yeah over
to like okay I had to put others first
like talk me through some of that stuff
well I made a lot of selfish decisions
you know and I think one of the biggest
things I can say that has been a huge
effect on me was I missed the first 14
years of my kids lives like those 14
years you know I was gone what 270 300
days a year and then when you're home
you just kind of drop off your dirty
laundry and prep for the next trip and I
was gone a lot and so I really you know
I'm grateful to my older kids 18 and 24
because especially my daughters worked
really hard to like maintain a
relationship with me she came out here
to go to SDSU
um and I missed a lot of that and but
now I got the second chance and I guess
my message to other people out there
that maybe made some bad decisions you
know not the teams of a bad decision
it's who I am you know I was I was made
for this but
you know I've got another shot with my
youngest son and you know I spend a lot
of time with that guy you know when I I
pick him up from school I work from like
4 30 a.m and I'm off by two and then
it's just he and I do our thing and uh
you know he's got a bunch of different
interests he does rugby he's here on the
mat a couple times a week but just that
time that I I give him it's for him and
you know I didn't do that for my first
two I was worried that they would be
like oh now you're gonna this is is he
your only real kid but they weren't
anything like that it's been cool I took
a trip to South Africa this summer with
uh my oldest that's where he wanted to
go he wants to be a vet and then and I
took a little fella and we self-directed
Safari in a Toyota Camry
there's lions like looking down animals
aren't hard to find there by the way
what's self-directed Safari you rent a
Camry step one step two you drive to the
wild animal park got it and you just
drive through that's it yeah because you
drive right up on them like I mean
hyenas elephants were you in South
Africa yeah I was in Kruger National
work yeah because that's the one thing
that I when I went to South Africa is
like there's no
like
there's only
Parks right there's no Lions walking
around in normal places no no but in the
Parks if you get out of your car you
could be lying right yeah right yeah
yeah I also made that mistake I got out
of the car sometimes did you hear the
story so I'm with Leif and his wife
Jenna and with our our friend Paul down
in in South Africa and we're driving and
we had to go from joburg to like this
place this this uh game reserve right
yeah so we're driving and we're talking
and we're you know whatever and I didn't
really realize it but we had gone from
like the world into the thing right yeah
yeah it happens fast right yeah but I
didn't really see but we went through
like a gate and everything but I didn't
really I don't know if I was doing
something else or whatever it's not like
America yeah so
we're dry and now it's getting dark but
the sun's going down and also it's like
a nice Sunset across you know like cool
like like little woods and like little
mountain thing and I'm like oh like hold
on let's get a picture and so like this
guy Paul stops the car and I'm like all
good and then I'm like you know I'll get
a better picture if I'm not in a car so
I just like open the door get out and I
start walking around like trying to find
that good angle with the tree in the
mountain or whatever
and
then I just said take a few pictures on
my whatever phone and then get back in
and dude like
hey Leif was like bro I don't know if
that was like a good thing and I was
like what do you mean he's like well
we're in like the wild animal park yeah
and I was like oh well you know kind of
like whatever yeah because in America
they can't eat you they don't have truth
or something but it turns out this dude
Paul
was like thinking like hey dude Jocko's
just freaking legit yeah he just doesn't
care like whatever whatever
no it was just joking stupid because the
real answer was Jocko's dumb and Joker
was almost dead because he was dumb but
I just got out was like just two him
around like oh we get a cool picture I
did the same thing freaking idiots I
pulled up on this like you could go on
the river and like these little pull
outs and a dirt road so I could get out
of the camera you know we walked down
and to walk I'm like oh there's Al
there's a Crocodile I'm gonna see a
crocodile so you walk down there and
well the crocodile was it's gone that
thing was setting up and then on top of
that there's an elephant in the in this
riverbed I'm like hey boys
we should walk back to the car like so
I'm walking and you know my boys are
like well I kind of want to look at the
elephant I'm like no no no I think we
need to go back to the car like so we
walk up the thing because and I can see
like you know elephants make big poops
and they're all over the place I was
like man this is like their thoroughfare
like we don't need to run into an
elephant here you know yeah that and I
saw uh a rhino right oh that's the
hardest one to see I didn't see one of
those so we saw one and
bro I was like we're in a Range Rover
and I was like this thing's looking at
me yeah and most of the things that I
look at in the world
I kind of think I can take them not this
way you know what I mean I'm kind of
like look dude unless you're like Jon
Jones like I look at Jon Jones be like
yo this could be a problem but even Jon
Jones you know I'll stick that you know
I'll stab him or something right I don't
know yeah you know whoever it is I feel
I think I can take them kind of yeah
right I'm at least gonna be able to
handle the situation but they're unarmed
I have a big knife yeah I didn't have a
knife because we flew in from you know
fluent on an aircraft so I didn't I was
too stupid I didn't go out and get a big
knife so I didn't have anything it's not
like you know I had to stick Jon Jones
like if that happens if I roll in
through Albuquerque no offense Jon Jones
Bones but uh no but seriously you know
you look around at people you're like
okay I'm gonna be okay I'm gonna be okay
yeah right but
this thing's looking at me yeah and it's
like we're in a car and I'm like this
thing will kill us all in this car if it
decides to right now yeah this was a
weird feeling dude do you see any hyenas
scary AF dude think about a jaw muscle
that goes straight into neck muscle I it
was hyenas are my favorite land animal
dude we pulled into a little chain link
fence and we camped there we pull up and
there's like you to me chain link fence
hyena my son I'm like dude this doesn't
seem super safe it's Jurassic Park ish
it is Jurassic where I was it was like
direct Jurassic Park they had like a
little electric wire like two little
electric wires yeah and on the other
side of it is elephants and they're
probably nons and yeah I don't know if
they were on power outage or whatever
but that's where we were at yeah same
thing because I pulled in camped in the
Camry like yeah well I'm glad you made
it home and I'm glad you're getting to
spend uh all this good time with with
your boys and with your daughter as well
who's just they're they're freaking
great kids no you know all my kids yeah
you've seen them so
um what else man does that get us up to
speed
I think it does
um we got May Day
executiveservices.com we got beyond the
brotherhood.org you're only on LinkedIn
yes sir that's all I have so it's Jimmy
man if you want to connect with Jimmy
May he's on LinkedIn
um
man Echo Charles yeah you got any
questions yeah I do all right so what's
up with the Humvees what they don't have
keys is that what's going on oh my gosh
yeah okay so yeah there's no there's
just a little switch there's no keys you
just switch it yeah and so I was an
idiot trying to find keys to the Humvee
yeah but I didn't want to tell anybody
so wait but if I buy like remember like
Arnold Schwarzenegger had that big
number I'm sure they were they they
probably so the ones overseas don't
there's actually not only is it you
switch but there's a little switch that
that like locks the lights because you
had to turn the lights on I didn't know
how to do that and I was trying to like
please let me turn these lights on right
because before Jocko looks because
there's one switch you have to like
unlock the little light thing and you
turn it over and some of them are ir and
Jocko's sitting there with his helmet on
like I'm like oh God
if I don't screw this up so technically
anyone can just take a Humvee then uh
yeah yeah well actually the way the
Marines and army do it they have a
little like lock and they just put a
lock on the door like a padlock like a
padlock oh damn so you can't hold and
it's like bulletproof stuff like it'd be
hard to tear that door off yeah yeah but
you could crawl into the top sometimes
if there's like like a crawling through
the turret yeah but sometimes they throw
some kind of chain around the freaking
steering wheel too like there's let's
face it there's some thievery going on
some borrowing going on yeah some
Acquisitions happening yeah uh just
about talking about like not wanting to
tell people when you're messed up man
you know about my first skydive
dude this is ridiculous so like I I go
through Free Fall school and you know
you get 22 jumps you know how good you
are 22 jumps you're not you're Sky trash
yeah so I just I have a buddy's on the
jump team and he wants to and I'm dating
this girl
he's like hey we're doing tandems can we
you want to take her for a town like oh
yeah cool so we take her down there and
he's like hey you want to jump with us
I'm like yeah I'll jump with you cool I
can jump so all I know is military right
so
I walk in I'm like what do I do he's
like hey just act like you're with us
I'm like Okay cool so these guys are
walking you know and they got sunglasses
and they're putting their hand out and
they put the left hand out and they
slide a parachute on their hand and then
they walk out the door right so I'm just
in the back of the line you know looking
cool swagger got my sunglasses on put my
hand out she puts this thing on me to my
horror it's like a Camelback like it
does not look like the kind of like
thing I know how to put on so usually in
the military I've got this giant
backpack right and then it has another
giant parachute underneath as well and
it's got like it's got buckles and like
this thing that'll pull the parachute
for me if I don't pull and then all
these things so I'm like well that's
okay I'll take care of it the jmpi the
Jumper's pre-inspection that's when
usually I walk out
and I have all my buckles and one person
who knows what he's doing looks at
everything I do look at all my buckles
then they spin me around they open up my
pins they look at every single thing and
then they like smack me on the back and
then I go to another guy who does the
same thing
and then I don't touch anything until I
get on the plane that's how it goes
right
so I'm thinking I'll just Square this
way at the jmpi I walk out
we turn left plane is spinning we get on
the plane I'm not even wearing my
parachute
so I'm now I'm like
I wonder quietly to myself how do I put
this parachute on so I step into the
bottom because I look at I've watched
other people do it because usually
there's two straps around my around my
legs then there's a belly band then
there's these two straps behind me that
I pull then there's another one goes
across my chest
and all those things you put together
there's you step through two straps and
put one thing across your chest and I'm
like
is that it it seems like there should be
more
so I'm looking at this thing and I'm
like
then I noticed that there's no thing for
me to pull to like open my parachute so
the plane's in the air and I'm I'm
flying my girlfriend is sitting on my
buddy's lap because he's like trying to
strap her in and I'm super concerned
that I don't know how to open my
parachute
and I'm like hey man I'm trying to get
his attention without letting her know
that I don't know what's going on and
I'm like hey man so where's my pool you
know he goes oh it's back here and
there's this little bean bag and I reach
back there and I feel it and I'm like
hey
what do I do do I squeeze it like what
he goes oh you just throw it
so now I'm in this plane this is
ridiculous I'm in this play dude 100
this is how it went down bro so I'm in
this place this is like this is this is
you might have to cut this no no this is
this is why the life expectancy of man
is freaking so much freaking lower than
women so now because this is a an idiot
and actually yeah so now we're going up
and I'm like
okay so I think I'm supposed to throw
this thing there's another little can
handle down here around my waist which I
can only assume is for my my backup
parachute which I hope there is one
because at this point I don't know
and
the light turns green and I gotta jump
before the tandem people jump so I turns
green
I jump out this plane
my clever plan for safety because
usually I pull it like thirty five
hundred four thousand like I decide to
pull it seven thousand because you fall
a thousand feet in six seconds that
gives me an extra like 18 seconds to
figure out how to fix my parachute if I
don't it doesn't work it's my clever
plan so I I reach I throw this thing as
hard as I can and it opens right it
opens
and usually my parachute goal is like
this giant parachute opens right it's
like 360 square feet of just giant
parachute goodness this thing goes
it's like a kite and I'm not even going
much slower than I was when I was
falling I'm like what is happening so
I'm like okay it looks like it's as big
as it's gonna get so maybe I should try
my canopy controllability check that's
what you do right I usually I look left
I shake my leg left so the people behind
me know I'm about to turn left and then
I pull my parachute down and it's like
whoa whoa and you kind of go slowly to
the side
this time
I look left I shake my leg I pull the
thing down I go above my parachute like
a series of yeah just just the the
military parachutes they're really big
they're 360 square feet yeah and they're
meant to be able to support you and your
weapon and your rucksack and all this
weight and so they're not very
maneuverable yeah and he's jumping a
little sport shoot it was probably if
I'm guessing it's probably like the jump
team there's like a 150 so and this was
super a long time ago so I don't know
what the they're like yeah they're like
like surfboard this is like a the a a
five nine surfboard like just a little
shred surfboard where he's used to
riding a longboard
yeah yeah so I come so now I decided not
to finish the rest of my chemical
controllability check because I am
horrified
I've seen these guys land these things
before because I can't yank it because
I'm going to pop up in the air like
you'll pop up to 25 feet and then just
like stall and fall so I'm like trying
to figure out how to land this thing and
I end up pulling it off pretty well and
my buddy his name was Johnny
dude you did great
oh my God I can't believe so anyway I
didn't jump civilian for a long time I
do now and I really understand how
stupid that was but at the time you know
I didn't want to admit that I didn't you
know at the time it made so much sense
don't want to look don't want to look
like a wimp bro no I mean come on bro oh
yeah that's like Tony Tony fatty told
the story on here he was like
he's absolutely horrified of heights and
Tony is he's horrified of heights and he
was repelling in like Hong Kong off of
you know some skyscraper in Hong Kong
like it's literally like a 500 foot
repel or something crazy like that and
he was like I was so freaking horrified
but I wasn't gonna look like a whim so I
didn't jump off you know like what are
you gonna do I don't know man and I told
that story and as the older I get the
stupider it sounds I'm like I cannot
believe dude I'm like cringing as you're
telling that story so the normal
protocol Echo is you go to a class they
teach you about it and then they send
you up with a free fall instructor so
like when I transitioned from jumping
the military rig to jumping the civilian
rig went to like a class and it's not a
big class but it's like one hour class
or something you sit there and you go
they put you down there and they're like
here it is you know here's how you throw
it out here's what you do with your
other hand here's the malfunction
procedures like you learn a lot of stuff
and then they take a military Free Fall
per or sorry a civilian Free Fall person
that's going to qualify you and they
jump with you next thing on to you
because think about this so even though
he only had 22 jumps he had definitely
developed the muscle memory before doing
one thing that if he does that it ain't
gonna work yeah like you'll die
so they sent an instructor out there and
the reason they send an instructor
because people have died as they're
scrambling looking for their rip cord
and it's not there so they they go oh
people die doing this so we send someone
so they see Jimmy doing the wrong thing
they'd be like no and they can signal to
them
they can pull it for you or something
like that no Jimmy's just going solo
he's in the aircraft doesn't even know
how this freaking thing I didn't even
wasn't even wearing it yet I didn't know
how to put it on I was like
I didn't want that chick to think I was
a wussy you know what I mean you made
the right call hell yeah
oh what else Echo you got any more
questions oh yeah you guys talked about
the what's it called the freaking talk
or the man talk after the trait scenario
yeah what are they saying or what's the
man talk technically so basically it's
kind of based on the man in the arena if
you've heard of that talk
um I think who who said the man
Roosevelt Roosevelt yeah the man in the
arena is like you know all you guys
cheering the guy that got in there and
did it right that's like that's that's
an accomplishment in itself even though
he lost even though he might have failed
whatever yep and that's kind of like
that's kind of the Crux of what we're
trying to tell this guy like hey you're
a great American you're a smart you're
strong you're capable you're going to do
great things just not in this community
yeah that's it and so that's what the
man talk and that was kind of our whole
a truck in a you know probably two
minute thing that they did and now we
have it's much more robust process I
really believe in it I think it's good
and I learned a lot about you know those
those three things you know the
community purpose and goals and I think
it was important so the man talk is oh
so it's not
so it's kind of like an encouraging
thought it's like a positive thing no
you quit no we're not we're done telling
you you suck in trouble yeah hey you
quit and it's like Hey listen I got to
get you back into the regular Navy
you're going to go into the Navy and you
could be the mcpon you could be super
high up and you're gonna do great
because these guys are super high
caliber guy even our quitters are
awesome dudes and if they have the right
attitude they go out and dominate yeah
you know what uh I don't know if I can
say but you know Mikey didn't make it
his first time yeah no Mikey didn't make
it his first time and neither did Mark
yeah yeah I mean I had I had George on
and we talked about it okay okay and he
was like yeah it's in the book uh you
know he like called him up like didn't
make it down he was crushed bro yeah and
yeah that's scary and I'll tell you what
like that thing about the man in the
arena
there's so many people that go obviously
there's people that go to Seal training
props respect yeah you went dude you
gave it a shot good for you moved your
family you trained for years you get
here didn't work and there's all kinds
of people that don't even do that man
yeah they don't even they don't even I
mean dude it takes courage and
commitment yeah to to go for it it
really does it's a huge step and listen
I think it's you
lately I've been when guys were asking
me about it I'm like hey
most people don't make it and most
people don't think they're that person
but you probably are the chances are you
probably are the person that's not going
to make it there's an 80 chance that
you're the person that's not going to
make it and you know what those stats
are low yeah I think that's what we say
but we know they're low because now you
got to compete to get into buds you come
into the combine and if you're not one
of the top run swim you don't even go
and that doesn't count against our
numbers because we got you know we gotta
like appease the higher ups like it's
not that bad 20 make it you know but
it's pretty bad and those guys go off to
the fleet and you know for the Navy they
get super high quality guys 70 of our
e-dogs they got degrees man at least a
four-year they just couldn't get a slot
as an officer because it's super
competitive so we get super high quality
guys and the attraits I mean they're
solid dudes and it's kind of cool seeing
them build this community after the
hrock you know what I mean yeah like
what do they do what happens to them
when they get dropped where do they go
so first they go to the ahrock they
spend at least minimum 24 hours there
and then they gotta make that call
before they leave the barracks you know
before they they leave supervision they
make call then they go back and they got
to finish sleeping you know they're
probably and then they gotta start
thinking about their next steps in life
and then you know there's a big
administrative machine that starts the
needs of the Navy you know when we went
through it was like you take your ASVAB
and here's the the rates open to you
they start talking about what their next
steps are and they have to spend at
least two years in the fleet before they
can come back historically people that
quit once don't have a good shot of
making it back through I mean you know
Mike and Mark were definitely outliers
um because we ran the numbers every
single way like the the highest the guys
that make it through the most are like
the academy officers because they live
that for four years they know what's
going on and they have a really compete
to get those yeah and they're living in
that cold they have a seal up there
teaching them so they're they're the
highest they're the most probable guys
to make it enlisted guys are probably
about I think 18 or something like that
when I was when I was there so it's
super low and you know to make it
through under the age of 20 is super
crazy I heard that's like five percent
super crazy yeah and those guys I mean
we we know a couple guys that have done
that me and Jason Gardner Jason Gardner
Jason Gardner he's a long time yeah bro
I didn't know he was that young yeah he
was yeah those guys when I was 18 I
don't think I I had I didn't have it I
don't think I had it I learned it in
college I learned something in my head
but I wouldn't had it at 18. no way
yeah that's a weird
it's a weird dynamic
um what else Echo Charles any more
questions all like that good to hang
with you cool good to see you too man
you know I I uh I I miss being on the
map with you guys I've got my hips
replaced recently and it's not
it's been a slower recovery than I was
I'd hoped for but you know it's good to
see you guys still out here training and
you know this is still home for me I
come to Victory and I know everybody
here and now my little boys training
here and it's just a happy place you
know I was like oh yeah we do the
podcast here I'm like oh my gosh it's
just like being home it's super easy man
I've been here since 06. we had to do
something for JT in here man that'd be
badass okay I know we got that one uh
mat that has like a flag and stuff on it
that'd be pretty cool to put something
up dude I got a cool picture of him next
to Hawkeye that was his his dog uh that
we took on the beach when we were living
in IB together same time when he was
working for you that'd be a really cool
one I have it at my house I wasn't sure
what to put up with it I don't have you
know California's small house I don't
have a lot of walls but it'd be cool to
put that up here maybe maybe we'll work
on doing that yeah I'll take that four
rack yeah man right on Jimmy any closing
thoughts bro no man I I uh you were a
mentor to me before you always been the
same to me I really appreciate you Jocko
you know uh you were hard on me when I
needed to be hard on and then you had a
profound effect on my careers I went up
and I think sometimes people will be
like oh that's one of those don't want
to Jocko's guys I'd be like you're damn
right you know what I mean so I
appreciate what you've done and you do a
lot of good things for teams I know that
there is an
and undercurring the team is like hey
these guys they're they go out and they
use the Trident for to leverage for
their own purposes but I know you do a
lot for the community and I appreciate
that and uh you know I'm trying to give
back as well so you know good to have
you guys as allies Echo man I love your
part your your little inserts are always
so key so I love having you here to keep
us sane because you're a drop corn I'll
just talk in acronyms and go in our own
little like violent agreement circle you
know but uh it's good having you here
yeah bro right on man well uh you know
like I said the day I met you I was like
cool this guy wants to do a good job and
he's tough and for me that's all that's
all I ever look for in in my friends you
know this guy wants to work hard do a
good job and it's tough so thanks for
coming down man thanks for uh sharing
your Lessons Learned thanks for your
service to the country to the Navy to
the teams and thanks for what you've
done for me over the years
and thanks for what you're continuing to
do today to help out guys and keep them
on track and get them moving in the
right direction finding their next
mission man I know you care about the
teams as much as I do and I know you're
still getting after it man thanks for
what you're doing
sir
and with that Jimmy May has left the
building
Jimmy May
always learning always improving
always trying to stay on the path there
you go you're not funny about Jimmy man
what's that how I knew how I like know
him and stuff
so you told me that story
about like about some guy yes this is
the uh challenge story you'll find out
yep you'll find out when we roll
I'm thinking back that might have been
the time when I realized who he was like
when I brought him together because I
met Jimmy man like trained with him a
bunch because he'd come during the day
and that's when like
you don't get a especially back then
there was no huge groups of people
training during the day prior to that
story
I'm oh I might have told you that story
a pretty late day yeah yeah you didn't
tell me right when it happened yeah yeah
in fact if I'm remembering correctly you
I told you
about maybe he came up or something like
that and then you were like oh let me
tell you this thing about and then I
think that's why I think that's and then
I put them all together so
so I was just training with him he was
just going he was like oh yeah I'm like
a Navy SEAL but you know back in the day
I freaking I know about you remember
Igor like all these guys my friends and
stuff like okay yeah everyone I meet
like you didn't say all the Navy SEAL he
said like probably oh yeah I'm in the
team right exactly I just want to make
sure you're not making Jimmy yes it's
not a direct quote that's for sure so so
I'm like cool and he's freaking good at
Jiu Jitsu and it's all you know I was
always really happy to see him so nice
he has a to be honest he kind of has a
scary look in his face when you look at
his face he looks like oh but it was
super nice he tried good training really
you know really good guy so I was always
looking forward to seeing him one night
too training right
slowly but truly freaking convert you
tell me that story I find out all this
stuff Greg tells me some stuff I'm like
freaking that's the guy that I used to
train with because I didn't train with
him for a long time
and I was thinking but that doesn't make
sense because he doesn't seem like he's
that guy because he's just a normal dude
sure enough that's the guy oh so before
you realized he was in the teams I knew
he was in the teams before I knew about
all the stuff he did okay and I didn't
even know about all the stuff but
the guy because I knew him just as Jimmy
not Jimmy May oh okay yeah because he
just said my name's Jimmy it's funny too
because
I always call him Jimmy May yeah me too
and then people in the teams call him
Jimmy May no one calls him just Jimmy
I call them Jimmy before I knew he was
Jimmy may you see I'm saying yeah yeah
so
uh there you go man train some Jujitsu
I'm kind of bummed he can't train right
now like hard you know he can roll a
little bit and stuff but I think he's
got you know he'll he'll he'll be there
he didn't go into the hole like hip his
hip yeah yeah
straight up like kind of gnarly yeah no
that's Nora dude when they're replacing
your hip it's gnarly period end of story
you know what I mean like they're taking
a major part of your freaking
skeletal structure out and replacing it
with metal
you know
so yeah that's that's what it is so
anyways but you know
the thing is Jimmy just like all of us
should be he's always constantly working
and trying to get better so
staying on the path there you go when
you do that
you need the proper fuel get yourself
some Jocko fuel it's true also that
pre-workout's out that's the new hotness
right now and I am back on the
pre-workers
the tingling actually I I shouldn't
because I didn't do it like a full
length workout but my workout was 35
minutes I still felt the tingling on the
way down here oh okay oh yeah that's
when you know how many minutes prior to
the workout commencing
are we 10 ingesting 10 and here's the
formula and I went over this with Carrie
by the way so if I'm working out right
when I get up here's the formula it's
the deluxe formula for pre-workout
creatine so it's water right water
creatine
scoop in half creatine one hydrate
charcoal hydrate
you think
it actually doesn't matter the flavor of
hydrate and then one scoop I'm at one
scoop now I started with half scoop oh
you're already I'm already one scoop
pre-workout those three all mix some
people like the greens which I dig I
advocate for the greens for sure but
that's not the deluxe formula I'm
currently on Boom perfect bro perfect
lands perfectly 10 15 minutes before the
workout boom go the tingling begins
so good so good perfect try that one
report back okay check there you go
jocofuel.com get yourself some of that
pre-workout get yourself some go
I'm two goes deep right now and I'm
getting ready to go train that
which you're not training today is that
what I heard not today no because you
already lifted apparently yes that's
what you said to me
I have a whole day 35 minute workout
today and you can't trade did you see
because of that yeah no I actually have
some videos I have to do right I gotta
do it you know prioritizing executing
okay right on all right yeah we'll also
get milk because how many mulks deep are
you right now two okay I am two so we're
both 60 grams by the way it's the only
thing I've eaten today yeah it's two
bottles of milk yeah
what flavors did you get banana and
chocolate I went vanilla then chocolate
that's a good nice to have the options
right little variety activity
normally I'm super um
boring right like stick with the same
oil yeah like go I only drink tactical
tea not only but like 80 of the time
tactical the Mainstay twenty percent of
the time I'm doing maybe some pink Mist
maybe some sour apple
maybe the lemon lime but 80 is the one
but I find myself with the Mulk mixing
it up a little bit more yeah
yep I see it I go from banana chocolate
I don't so much do the vanilla do you do
the um the Bluegrass or girl Bluegrass
goes out yeah yeah just came out yeah
yes I do like it I do like it I
surprisingly like it too I'm gonna say
this light and refreshing
well you know the mega mix too I don't
know if you heard me explain this to
Carrie the mega pre-workout mix okay go
it's the same mix but with a go but with
the go instead of water oh yeah so you
get the Blu-rays you stack the blue Ras
all day so you blue res go Blue res
hydrate blue res pre-workout triple
broom threat boom oh yeah then I mean I
don't know if that's you know you put
the greens down
yeah yeah you got to cut it well you got
to put creatine as well so that's the
mega mix right there but I can't take
responsibility for the results on that
one because you can be wigging out
jacked yeah
all right get this stuff jacofuel.com
get it at Wawa get it at Vitamin Shoppe
GNC the military commissaries a fees
Hannaford's Dash doors wake from
ShopRite HEB down in Tejas Meyer up in
the midwest Harris Teeter Lifetime
Fitness Shields and by the way small
gyms everywhere
and if you own a small gym you own a
little Jiu Jitsu Academy you own a
CrossFit gym you own a power lifting gym
whatever you own email JF sales.com and
get yourself some of the stuff for so
you can give your clients the product
normally that sounds bad like we would
have given some product that's like drug
dealers right to give you a free
whatever problem you're addicted to
heroin yeah you know what I mean you're
addicted to crystal methamphetamine sure
then you die you commit crimes and then
you lose your teeth and then you die yes
this is the opposite yeah you actually
commit good workouts you grow stronger
and you live better the real good so get
some people some product geography.com
let's go that's true what else also
origin USA Bulma so we're doing Jiu
Jitsu we're working what are we doing
not working oh we're working so look
doing Jiu Jitsu you're gonna need a ghee
once you go with these origin geese
you're not going to go back to the
regular conventional
uh Sweatshop geese
and you are working too so you need a
pair of jeans maybe two can you wear
black jeans in a elevated uh scenario
restaurant like it's Valentine's Day or
something hell yeah oh yeah big time I
mean we're in California so we're kind
of messed up because in California you
can roll out Valentine's Day five-star
restaurant flip-flops t-shirt surf
shorts oh yeah you might get a little
bit of like a look but they're still
letting you in no Factor you're probably
getting no Factor no Factor yeah but if
you know if you're trying to like maybe
step it up a little bit you might want
to put on the black jeans yeah you might
as well get ones that are made in
America that's true don't get ones that
are made in a sweatshop no freaking
wrong that's just wrong don't let that
happen originusa.com get yourself some
gear hunt gear just went hunting by the
way didn't kill
it's okay but I had a freaking awesome
time yeah
uh cam Hanes
had a elk two yards from him that he
shot and killed he's wearing the origin
camo the thing was just like standing
there didn't see it it really worked bro
what better proof do you want I know you
got the proof man you don't get any more
camo than that two yards away elk two
yards it is natural habitat look if I'm
in my house if you're two yards away I
don't care don't care you can be the
Predator from you know the movie brother
you can be the bro I'm gonna see it two
yards 100 in my house yep right that's
my house I know when the house seems
different see what I'm saying so the elk
couldn't even see him could even see him
in that origin Raptor camo
so get yourself some hunt gear hide from
what you're trying to kill
uh jockostore.com we make some stuff we
make some T-shirts we make some rash
guards they're actually origin stuff but
yeah you know a little bit different
designs but yeah the rash guards for
margin boom first you know that's how
we're rolling 100 but yeah if you want
to you want to represent good discipline
equals Freedom we got your shirts and
hoodies and hats I posted a video of you
the other day you were in a work where
you were wearing a shirt that was like
disciplined but it was in a GI Joe font
format sure format and font yeah the
whole deal yeah and there was a bunch of
comments said where do I get that shirt
and you replied shirt Locker shirt
Locker well that could have been
slightly cryptic because yes it's from
the Sherlock but the shirt Locker is
part of Jocko's store it's our program
so yeah man you want to get on that the
short Locker program it's one new shirt
every month that's just one of many that
you can get good news too that is a past
one that one's from last year
like 2022 last year can you still get it
you can still get it so if you're a
member of shirt Locker boom we give you
a little account you just log in you
freaking buy whatever one you want from
the past so you have access to all that
stuff but yeah you share it every month
people seem to like the design it's
funny because a lot of people don't know
about it or put it this way less people
know about it than I thought because
even like you know the video that we put
out or you put out of you dead lifting
and the shirt changing all the time
you're like oh my gosh where do where do
I get that shirt or whatever you know
and these are like bro they've been up
man shirt Locker all day so yeah good
cool but yeah now we know jacostore.com
just click on join the shirt Locker
check them out subscribe to the podcast
subscribe to Jocko underground we're
recording one of those actually maybe
two of those this this weekend hit those
up some q a answer your questions give
you the info
it's 8.18 cents a month why because
people get kicked off of platforms and
there's nothing they can do about it
they're not prepared we're prepared
hopefully it doesn't happen well we're
good we're over here
we're just putting out word but
sometimes people might think the word
we're putting out shouldn't be put out
then what are we gonna do we'll be there
on the Underground if you can't afford
eight dollars and 18 cents a month we
get it tough times out there email
email assistance Jocko underground.com
we'll take care of it subscribe to the
YouTube channel subscribe to our buy
psychological warfare flipsidecanvas.com
Dakota Meyer making Kick-Ass stuff for
you to hang on your walls got a bunch of
books you know what they are hey defend
Us in battle
I covered that already with George
monsor
also Rose Ray she co-authored that she's
a military spouse she did a great job
George Monsour just incredible book
defend Us in battle the story of Mikey
Monsour get that book and then I've
written a bunch of books you know what
they're got a new version of leadership
strategy and tactics coming out expanded
a dish
I put some very pertinent and pragmatic
useful information into this new version
so check that I was also got a dope
Black cover
which is kind of where everything ends
up you know for me like we trials just
let's go let's make it black
looks dope right it's true it looks
badass so either there you go new
version of leadership strategy and
tactics Field Manual then all the other
books the kids books I've written get
those Echelon front we have a leadership
consultancy we solve problems through
leadership go to aslamfront.com come to
one of our Live Events bring us into
your organization have us come and talk
to your leaders about leadership let us
get you aligned
that's what we're doing
everything that we do sells out so if
you want to come to one of our events
get there early go to ashlandfront.com
check it out we also have online
training extreme ownership.com it's our
online Training Academy we have a lot of
information we we have the skills that
we learned and there's skills that you
can learn and if you don't have the
skills of leadership your whole life is
worse period end of story
and what is leadership it means you're
interacting with other human beings
husband wife kids employees boss peers
everybody friends everybody family
everybody you're interacting with other
people
in order to do that effectively you need
to understand leadership extreme
ownership.com learn how to lead
also if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families gold star families check
out Markley's mom mommy she's got an
incredible charity organization she
helps with medical procedures and
treatments that are not covered by the
military
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to America's
mightywarriors.org also don't forget
about Micah think taking taking our
veterans up into the Wilderness to find
themselves Heroes and horses.org and
Jimmy's organization that we talked
about today beyond the brotherhood.org
if you want to connect with us
Jimmy can be found on the interwebs May
Day executiveservices.com and Beyond the
brotherhood.org
and if you want to reach out to Jimmy
May he's on LinkedIn and then for Echo
and I we are also on all these different
social media platforms that exist
echoes.com Charles I'm at Jocko link
just be careful because the algorithm is
a big beast and it'll try and grab you
and waste a bunch of your time and your
life so don't let that happen thanks
once again to Jimmy
Jimmy May thanks for your service thanks
for your sacrifice and thank you for
everything you are doing to continue to
help our community and our Brotherhood
and thanks to all the men and women in
uniform around the globe at this very
minute protecting us and our way of life
and also thanks to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service and all First
Responders all of you continually step
into Harm's Way for us and our families
and we thank you for keeping us safe and
everyone else out there
you know I started off this podcast by
reading about Mikey Monsour
and what he did in the sacrifice that he
made will on
his gravestone
at Force Fort Rosecrans National
Cemetery chiseled at the bottom of his
gravestone
it simply reads no regrets
and that's the way that he lived and
that's the way that he died no regrets
and it's a good reminder to all of us
and I believe
that for most of us the biggest regrets
come
not from what we have done
but what we didn't do
so let there be no regret about what we
could have done about what we could have
accomplished about what we should have
done
let's leave nothing in the tank
leave it all on the field no ammunition
to spare nothing left inside
let's go with no regrets
and we do that by going out there every
day
and getting after it
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko
out